e
e e
is an alert for people waiting for the
beginning of our session due to some
weather related travel issues we are
going to delay the start of this
executive session to allow members who
are grappling with snow squalls to uh
arrive
safely so stay
tuned
e
e e
is happening here we have a executive
schedule a session schedule for 9:00 but
the weather has prevented a couple of
our members from arriving promptly
although representative partial made it
thankfully um representative PL seems to
be our
only looks here he comes here he comes
we will begin
shortly okay good morning everyone and
welcome to the
science technology and energy committee
on New Hampshire Senator Jean Shaheen's
birthday happy birthday Senator we'll
begin our session today with an exec
session and then we'll follow that with
some public hearings on four separate
bills uh which we will describe in more
detail later on but we'll start our
meeting as is our custom by asking you
to all rise and join
representative Tony Kaplan as he leads
us in the Pledge of
Allegiance United States of America to
the stands
Nation
indivisible and justice for all
so we will begin our meeting this
morning with an executive session on
three
bills and then we'll follow that with
public hearings starting at 10:00 so
first up I'm going to open an executive
session on House Bill
95- FN requiring the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op to regularly file a
certificate of deregulation with the
Public Public Utilities Commission and
I'm going to recognize representative
nder for a motion motion thank you Mr
chair I um move
itl be recognizes representative
PL i' like to Second uh House Bill 95
moved and seconded that we adopt the
motion of itl for House Bill 95 FN
discussion representative
nder yes the um New England Electric
Cooperative is owned by the members the
the ones who use the utility or the ones
who own the utility they're not for
profit if they're a true democracy so if
uh such a a measure was going to be made
it should be made by the members of the
utility to be deregulated would mean
that the Pu would have to get involved
and then higher additional staff and
that the the cost would have to be
recouped by the rate payers the
estimated cost is over $600,000 so uh we
should itl this Bill thank
you thank you further uh comment
representative
rolds uh thank you Mr chairman I um I
understood uh representative Wendy
Thomas's intent in this bill uh
not not to
be uh a requirement
that the co-op become re-regulated but
rather that it was I I understood her
bill to be more of sort of a a good
government bill that would have required
the co-op to sort of recertify
itself
um to restate and update the reg the
reasons that they should U stay
unregulated on a regular basis and I
even looked at it as sort of a reason
and a vehicle for the New Hampshire
co-op to publish a report for all in the
state to see including the other
utilities and this committee and the
public uh you
know how and why they were able to do
things so well for their
members so um you know I'll be voting
against the motion of it further
discussion
representative Wendy Thomas thank you
chair um New Hampshire requires a
certificate of deregulation or
regulation um for the for the uh for the
co-op um the reason I filed this bill is
I think it's good governance to update a
required document more than every
quarter of a century and it's been 24
years since this last uh document was
updated furthermore all of the testimony
including the introduction to this uh
motion uh talked about the price of
going to
regulation I was under the impression
that the members were very happy with
the way the co-op was being run right
now and the fact that there is so much
concern that the members might vote for
regulation has raised flags for me and
and I think that that makes this bill
even more important thank
you further
discussion as a co-op member I
will add my voice to this uh debate and
suggest that we the members of the co-op
are the ones who should determine how
the co-op is
run that's what a member owned
organization does and we don't need to
be scrutinized by outside influences or
outside
entities so I think that itl is the only
way to go with this bill to respect the
wishes of the members of the
co-op any further
discussion representative McGee I'll
just chime in because I think there are
um differing opinions all all throughout
the committee uh after hearing the
testimony that we heard I'm not inclined
to push this
forward for my personally and I
certainly do understand the position of
my colleagues on my side um I uh
understand that the position of the
co-op is fairly unique in our Energy
System and that uh their deregulated
status is well understood and their
nonprofit status is um other than CP cnh
coming in you know it was a unique
status for a very long time and so
um while I think it is not a bad idea to
have regular renewals um I think their
status uh is is pretty well understood
and so um their position really is that
it's redundant for them to say we're
we're deregulated because the whole
premise of the way they're Incorporated
is is that they're deregulated they're
not a regulated utility so I'm I'm
probably going to vote for the itl
because I'm not sure that we
you
know that it's going to be
uh that
it's I'll just leave it
there okay further discussion
representative
PL thank you chair um I second it as a
member um things got brought up in
testimony and here in executive session
I
attended the last meeting that was
mentioned and um Mr cre got he got
involved in that by making suggestions I
attended that meeting I saw difference
of opinions from members and the board
it was
handled
civil um workers members we were all
there it was handled like any other
business went on we have another board
of directors um because of
resignations and uh one other thing the
petitions there have been
petitions when members are disg grunted
it does not take that many members I'm
not sure what the count is right today
to put in a petition to deregulate if
the
membership so feels in 25 years there
has not been a petition that I know of
that met the minimum requirements of
signatures so I will be voting my second
to itl thank you further discussion
representative Thomas Thomas thank you
Mr chair I just want to add my uh
concurrence that I plan to vote uh for
itl based on uh the evidence that we
heard and the fact that uh if I'm using
an old military uh col cism uh it seems
like U the co-op has functioned as
designed they had meetings they had
members that voiced their opinion and
the process indicates that members still
want to be unregulated and the to have
the legislature involved in mandating a
periodic review which is timely and can
cost some uh seems um redundant and not
in the faith of the uh of the way the
co-op is run by its member board so for
those reasons I support itl
further discussion representative Corman
thank you uh I actually will be voting
for the motion um I understand the
concept behind the bill and I appreciate
it but it it's uh we heard during
testimony that members can actually
revisit deregulation during the annual
election each year so if there really is
a move to um uh regulate members do have
that power so I'll be voting for the
motion further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of itl for HB
95-n Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative Bry yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas
no representative Corman
yes Representative rolds
no representative La roelle
yes representative Swanson yes chairman
Vose yes
okay three 15 to
three okay by a vote of 15 to3 the
motion to itl HB 95- FN is adopted
representative nter will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report yes by representative Thomas
representative Wendy Thomas will write
The Minority Report
and that report will do be due by 7 a.m.
tomorrow morning it's in your
inbox oh okay thank you all right with
that we'll close the exec session on
House Bill
95- FN and move immediately to open an
exec session on House Bill
189 defining clean energy and the
department of Energy's 10year State
energy strategy to in include new
technology smallscale nuclear energy
renewable energy and fuel diversity and
removing references to the Energy
Efficiency and sustainable energy board
and the chair recognizes Vice chair
Thomas for a motion thank you Mr chair I
motion to adopt uh Amendment 2025 d01
05h and um I'll wait to speak to the
amendment chair recognizes
representative bernardy second the
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
Amendment 225-1581
and uh I said I would entertain
discussion on some changes to my uh my
bill which we we looked into and this
amendment incorporates uh the intent of
that discussion by adding low greenhouse
gas emitting sources as part of clean
energy definition including nuclear and
other renewable sources I believe that
covers the intent of uh the cons
concerns of how we Define clean energy
therefore um with that definition uh the
second part of the amendment to um place
the word clean energy and uh uh
Diversified fuels under the 10-year
strategy plan holds and would go back up
to the the uh the overall definition for
clean energy and one thing that we that
we forgot to mention during public
hearing but as was explicitly stated
this all o covers a housekeeping rule to
eliminate the reference to the uh easy
board which is now defunct so that's
just a housekeeping measure as
well discussion on the amendment
representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman um so this
amendment is different from the one that
we saw uh
yesterday and this one says clean energy
means low greenhouse gas emitting
sources not zero greenhouse gas emitting
sources and and I'm I'm concerned
about the lack of definition of what is
low greenhouse gas emitting does that
include natural gas for example and it's
just it's
undefined so you know what does it mean
to be low greenhouse gas emitting so I'm
I'm not in favor of the this amendment
as as written the one that we got
yesterday um I actually would have voted
for but this one uh I I can't vote for
because because it's I think not clearly
defined and I don't consider natural gas
to be clean energy I think of it as less
dirty energy but I don't think of it as
clean
energy further discussion representative
bernardy yeah I I think the uh the
rationale for using the word low versus
no is because things like
windmills uh have uh diesel or gas
engine
on board in order to start them from a
dead stop when the wind isn't blowing
and then starts picking up so they are
not zero emitting they emit a certain
amount of uh greenhouse gas so
you unless we're going to get into
real uh semantics on what low versus no
means um this is probably the best
alternative representative Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chairman um well uh
this was a result of the discussion we
had yesterday and trying to um entertain
the concerns at the time we uh my intent
for this change was the fact that we
didn't really mention hydrogen and so it
was the hydrogen is what we were
thinking of when we went to low low
emission uh you know sources so in our
efforts to uh to make sure we
incorporated that type of potential fuel
is why we came up with this
definition further discussion
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Vice chair for um
accommodating me in uh the discussion
that I thought the original language
wasn't broad enough to capture our
intent of defining clean energy for the
State of New Hampshire um what I wanted
to say about this particular language is
similar to what's been said already what
I had asked for yesterday was that clean
energy uh the term clean energy be
defined as non-greenhouse gas emitting
sources and non-greenhouse gas emitting
sources is a a sort of a it's a
nomenclature that's used in many
statutes around the country
non-greenhouse gas emitting sources
means that they don't create
they don't create emissions by their use
right so that doesn't mean that um you
know in the example that representative
Bernardi gave there may be still some
dependencies on fossil fuels for aspects
of production but when they're actually
in use producing The energy they produce
they don't Emit and so it is very
important that we get the language right
because there are many other statutes
that will refer back to what are we
talking about um our renewable energy
credits and the people you know the the
types of resources that we have now that
depend on those um I I feel like first
Do no harm and it so I think we should
get this right and if this amendment
doesn't satisfy that because it's now
including low greenhouse gas emitting
sources as clean which changes the
definition completely for even the
reason that we would have a clean energy
definition um and uh yeah so I think it
doesn't do what it is we were asking it
to do and the whole reason I brought up
the fact that I didn't think it met the
intent was that I wanted us to get it
right so again what I had mentioned was
non-greenhouse gas emitting sources
because it's a well-defined term that
people and people understand what's
included in that and nuclear is included
in that um so most of the clean energy
standards that you see being adopted
around the
country refer to non-greenhouse gas
emitting sources so that's what I think
it should be further
discussion representative
ner thank you Mr chairman um wind and
solar cannot be manufactured without the
use of fossil
fuels there's coal plants going up every
month every week in uh in China to to
make these components wind and solar
cannot replace fossil fuel but nuclear
can and nuclear is net zero um so I
support the the amendment oh also
interesting to note that in the state of
Ohio they include natural gas in their
definition of clean energy that'll never
happen here but still interesting to
note representative Swanson had a
comment thank you uh representative
Bernard you had a good point uh if there
are generators that are needed to start
the window Mills But ultimately I feel
like uh and and a good point as far as
yes uh I do believe that uh that nuclear
solar and wind can potentially replace
fossil fuel in the future it will take a
bit of a transition but I feel that the
the low greenhouse gas term is just too
vague and uh so this shouldn't be
supported any additional comment
representative Harrington you just to
clarify uh the same issue applies with
nuclear except on a much larger scale
when a nuclear plan is starting up they
either they generally will use grid
supplied power which in New England is
about 50% natural gas and it's a
substantial amount of power because you
have to heat up the plant operating
temperature by running the reactor
coolant pump and uh so they they do use
in cause emission of fossil fuels um
just so people are aware of that
additional comment representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman I'd just
like to add that uh um being here two
things being here in the term 2010 2012
um natural gas was being pushed by both
sides of the legislature as clean energy
back then granted A lot's changed over
the last 13 14 years but that was
actually being pushed to be spread more
throughout New Hampshire now as far as
uh cleanergy I'd like to go back to to
last term where we had actually a bill
on green that kind of ties to this with
the green um hydrogen and while green
hydrogen was being pushed in the bill we
kind of came to a consensus bipartisan I
believe that all types of hydrogen
whether it' be green purple or gray
would be um thought thought it would be
efficient as long as you be able to
produce into a hydrogen base then you
get zero so you'd have to start out with
again a low base to get to it's kind of
like the windmill example that
representative Bernardi used you have to
use a low base carbon to be able to get
to the zero base hydrogen that devices
or equipment Implement would use so
therefore I do see the wording for low
and maybe defining it a certain way to
meet certain expectations on the
development but um yeah I agree with the
the amendment is written
thanks representative
PL thank you excuse excuse me thank you
chair um going back to uh representative
Doug
Thomas and
um represent Summers the hydrogen green
hydrogen when it is used it combusts
into water vapor which is the most
um absorbing of the three greenhouse
gases methane and cl too so it if we're
planning to look into hydrogen we need a
low
Mission natural
um
CO2 thank you representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman uh try to be
brief here
um you know
dependencies for manufacturing or
perhaps startup are are well known and
and are commonly
understood um you know we live in a
world today large powered by fossil
fuels
uh that's that's not in in debate uh but
this is a bill in which we are this the
point of this bill is to Define clean
energy so the last thing we ought to be
doing is passing an amendment in a bill
that attempts to Define clean energy but
yet includes another
term now
low greenhouse gas emitting in which
there apparently are are widely even
among this discussion we're having you
know differing interpretations of what
low emitting means you know I want to go
back to what representative McGee
said about the term non non-greenhouse
gas emitting being a commonly used term
to refer to the sources of energy that
when they are operating the conversion
that they're doing of energy is
non-emitting and so we should be using
non- Greenhouse gas emitting not
low a widely used term that's not
correct would be problematic I would
think we need to move along so
representative Kaplan gets the last word
here yeah thank you Mr chair and you
know it it seems like we want to have a
tighter definition of what greenhouse
gas or what greenhouse gas or
non-greenhouse gas emitting sources
would be and from this discussion it
seems clear that that
would you know for our purposes it would
mean non-greenhouse gas emitting during
operational times and of low duration in
the atmosphere because yeah water vapor
is is a greenhouse gas but it lasts such
a little time that it actually has no
impact on you know on the on on the on
the warming which is what we're
concerned about so I mean that would be
a a simp if we want to be really precise
that would be a very simple Amendment we
could say non greenhouse gas emitting
during operational times and of low
duration in the atmosphere
all right I think we can uh I think
we've all had a chance to State our
position on this so I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of amendment you do
015h and uh based on the discussion I
think we should do a roll
call so I had discussed with the clerk
the possibility of adopting this
amendment with a show of
hands and he did not prepare a roll call
sheet as a result so it's going to take
him a minute to get uh established
here Vice chair Thomas yes
representative nder yes representative
Harrington yes representative Bry yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parall no representative Kaplan no
representative Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman Vos
yes
108 so the committ the the amendment is
adopted by a vote of 10 to8 chair now
recognizes Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chair I motion for uh HB 189 as
amended
otpa chair recognizes representative
bernardy second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
do we need any further discussion on
this I think we all know uh how we feel
about
it okay let's uh I'll ask the clerk to
call the road then on the question of
oop pass chair I just deferred to Tom
because he had his hand up he
was oh I'm sorry I didn't see you Tom
did you have a comment yeah just a quick
comment which is um I'll be voting
against the motion of otpa because I I
don't care for this amendment as I said
before had we been voting on yesterday's
amendment I actually would have vote for
the bill as amended but I will be voting
against the bill with the amendment that
just
passed okay with that I'll ask the clerk
to call the role in the question about
to pass is amended on House Bill
189 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
not yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle yes representative Swanson no
uh
117 oh repres excuse me chairman vot I
vote I vote yes thank
you 11 to7 so by a vote of 11
to7 the committee adopts the resolution
of ought to pass as amended on House
Bill
hb89 representative Vice chair Thomas
will write the majority report rep will
there be a Minority Report there will be
and I I'll be writing it representative
McGee will write
the majority report I mean Minority
Report and I need that by 7 amm tomorrow
please and with that we will close the
exact session on House Bill
189 and immediately open an exact
session on House Bill
627 and I will make a motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 6 627 and recognize
representative Matson I'd like to Second
it representative Matson seconds the
motion so it is been moved and seconded
that we judge House Bill 627 to be uh
worthy of the motion of ought to
pass as I stated yesterday when I
introduced this bill this is enabling
legislation that allows the puc to
designate cell phone carriers to be
purveyors of Lifeline
Services this bill will significantly
assist lowincome Granite
Staters as they try to access these
Lifeline Services which can include tele
medicine and easier ways to contact
Health Pro Health Providers they can
Prov it can provide internet service
where people might not be able to afford
internet service on their own so this is
um quality legislation that's been
adopted widely across the country and I
think it's time for New Hampshire to
join the rest of the states who have
determined that this
is valuable legislation for the
less uh fortunate members of our
society further comments on this
bill representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman uh I I was
actually the only Democratic co-sponsor
on the bill and um I I agree with with
the intent here
um these days a lot of people don't have
landlines might not have access to uh to
good internet but they might have cell
phones with some cell phone access and I
I think this is pretty reasonable uh I
was a little surprised that we got very
little public input on this uh we had no
signups on the blue sheet either way and
I looked online and it was one for and
one against so not a lot of public
input any other comments representative
rolds uh thanks Mr chairman I less less
a comment more than a a question um for
you do do you think is there anything um
that goes along with the lifeline
designation that the Pu May confer um
that might help in uh places
where cell phone coverage is is spotty
and they have trouble sighting antennas
uh you know for example like somebody's
going to be relying on their cell phone
for a Lifeline but they live in an area
where the coverage isn't very good
that's might be a problem so you know
like there's places on the Sea Coast
where they they can't seem to get a
tower in because there's local
opposition to a tower and yet if people
were relying on their cell phone to call
and they have a heart attack
they so I'm hoping you know that this
will help sounds like a an opportunity
for another bill maybe next
year further comments representative
Wendy Thomas thank you uh Mr chair um
during testimony um I had heard someone
and I I didn't I didn't um write down
who said it but um if it ain't broke
which this apparently isn't then don't
fix it
so I would like some clarification of of
why this move is important if it seems
to be working right now and I would like
that from from you the sponsor
please well as I said in my opening
remarks here this is enabling
legislation and it's very likely that
the kind of people who could benefit
from the life line services that the
expansion of Lifeline service capability
that this bill would provide don't even
know that
this that Lifeline Services exist but
they may find out about it at some point
and may be distressed to discover that
they can't access those Services is all
if all they have is a cell phone they
don't own a computer or have the ability
to connect to the Internet or have a
landline so
so I I would disagree with
your characterization of this as of the
existing system as
being
uh not broke I would say it is broke if
some people can't take advantage of
Lifeline
Services any further
discussion Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chairman I'll be voting in favor of
the OTP motion I just want to add that
it was my understanding anyway that life
sign services Lifeline Services are not
the same thing as 911 911 is a totally
different program which is available all
the time on mobile phones or landline
phones my understanding is that LIF line
services could incorporate things for
even the handicap like Clos caption when
it comes across their screen or things
of of of that nature so this is a a
different program and if this bill
enhances the ability to assign a carrier
for it then I'm I'm all for
that additional
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of the
motion of ought to pass for House Bill
627 M chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parall yes representative
Kaplan yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman vote
yes
180 by a vote of 18 to Zer the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill
627 without objection we'll put this on
the consent
calendar no objection so it goes on
consent and I of course will write the
committee
report so with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill 62 7 and
that wraps up our executive session work
for this morning so we have a break of
approximately 15 minutes before we start
our public hearing activity so we'll see
you once again in uh at 10
o'clock
e
e e
it's uh 10:00 and it's time to start our
public
hearing this morning and into the
afternoon the uh bill on the docket
right now is HB
504 relative to the state energy policy
and I would like to welcome
representative chairman Michael Vose uh
to speak on its behalf and intro the
Bill thank you Mr Vice chairman and good
morning once again to members of the
committee for the record representative
Michael Vose I represent rocking ham 5
the town of effing and I'm here to
introduce this morning House Bill
54 this bill was the policy of the house
last year last term it was passed by the
house by 16 votes and when it got to the
Senate the Senate uh rejected the first
part of the bill and passed the second
part of the bill which starts
um on line 24 it says two loss of
instate instate electrical generation
capacity and the reason I resubmitted
this bill is because I think it's
important for New Hampshire energy
policy to emphasize affordability and
reliability and also to try to insulate
and protect the rate
payers and the citizens of New Hampshire
from the intrusion of policies that we
don't necessarily agree with from our
neighbors to the north south east and
west so what this bill does
and I'm not going to go through it line
by line because as I said we passed this
bill last year so it's pretty well
understood by most members of this
committee
but essentially just puts into statute
some important principles that we need
to pay very close attent attention to it
is our responsibility as members of the
legislature to protect the health safety
and Welfare of our citizens and one of
the ways we can do that is to make sure
that they have affordable reliable and
secure energy
resources and that's what the Bill does
it puts into statute
the principles and ideas that will allow
us as a as a state to seek
out energy resources that are affordable
and
reliable I am open to the idea that
maybe some of the language in this bill
could be improved and I've already
talked to some folks who have some
suggested improvements to make and so
likely when we bring this bill to
Executive session we will offer some uh
wording changes that will make it an
even better Bill than it was when it
passed the house last
year so with that introduction uh Mr
Vice chair I'd be happy to take
questions from the
committee questions
representative Coleman
kman I keep getting you mixed up with
thank you Mr Vice chair I'm gonna have
to work with you on how to pronounce my
name I keep getting mixed up with the
Coleman Gast over think of Harvey Corman
from the Carol Bernett show spelled
differently but pronounced the same or
or Roger Corman the the movie director
anyway thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
Mr chairman for taking my question
uh when I look at the bill uh I'm
looking at page one line 7 which talks
about without preference toward
technology type and then line 13
allowing Market forces and line 16 and
17 uh according to Market
principles and I think about um how our
governor talked about having an all of
the above energy
strategy and um it seems like all all of
this is consistent with what our
governor govern has said on the other
hand our governor has said and we
actually have a pending uh house
concurrent resolution prohibiting
offshore
wind so these that seems to be at odds
with saying that there's uh without
preference toward technology type and
and relying solely on Market forces and
I'm wondering uh is there a way to
reconcile these two Notions
yes I believe there is because the major
emphasis of this
legislation is affordability and
reliability and offshore wind cannot
provide energy that's affordable or
energy that's
reliable now offshore wind might be part
of the energy mix if it can be shown to
be affordable and reliable if it ever
gets to that point currently it it's far
from that point but if it ever gets to
that point then certainly it could be
part of the
mix and there will probably be
additional language added to this uh
bill at Amendment time to emphasize that
fuel diversity is a value that we that
we hold that energy policy should
seriously
consider so I think the affordability
reliability question reconciles with the
technology neutral aspect of energy
policy in that yeah we don't care what
it is as long as it's in affordable and
reliable follow up follow up thank
you so I can't disagree that uh wind
currently is is not very favored in the
market and and you know it's the wind
does not always blow uh that's certainly
true on the other hand
um given that there is a possibility of
an HCR about prohibiting offshore wind
uh I am concerned about that conflicting
with this statement about without
preference toward technology type we
would have an HCR that conflicts with
something that could be in statute and
um I'm I'm just
wondering how to reconcile those two
things when you say that is your a
question coming up here well yeah just
wondering how to reconcile that when
when we say that we can't have offshore
win but then we say without preference
it seems like those two things are at
odds and I I just I'm just wondering can
those be reconciled in
language well the answer to that
question would be maybe we haven't heard
HCR two or four I forget what the number
of the resolution is we haven't heard
that uh we haven't decided whether that
will even pass so uh I don't see that
it's necessary for us to reconcile that
at this point in time but even if the
resolution were to pass it's non-binding
it's a
resolution uh representative
Bernardi just to add a little uh
frosting to that cake
um the this bill talks about all
Technologies being considered and so
windmills per se are not uh disfavored
the location of windmills is the issue
at hand and uh because the offshore
nature of them creates uh far more uh of
a greater reliability and cost uh
concern than potentially landbase
windmills was that a question no it's a
comment
too representative
McGee thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you Mr chairman um I I was here for um
the the version of this that we had in
the last uh bium and I was also on the
subcommittee where we agreed that we
would
maintain 3 7837 which this bill repeals
and
replaces and I I wanted to offer to my
colleagues who are not familiar with the
um basically the definition of New
Hampshire's energ energy policy that
exists it's quite brief but it's also
comprehensive and that it it lists all
the things we're talking about but it
does it in a more elegant way it says
New Hampshire energy policy the general
court declares that it shall be the
energy policy of the state to meet the
energy needs of the citizens and
businesses of the state at the lowest
reasonable cost while providing for
reliability and diversity of energy
sources to maximize the use of
cost-effective Energy Efficiency and
other demand side resources
and to protect the safety and health of
the citizens the physical environment of
the state and the future supplies of
resources with consideration of the
financial stability of the state's
utilities so it really is an
all-encompassing very simple single
paragraph and all of these sections
would overwrite this paragraph so that
the effort that was made to keep it
comprehensive but very simple so that
anyone could just read the state's
energy policy and understand that it
included all those
things coming there well I'm trying to
provide context that other members don't
have for the many many many many
conversations that led to this bill
being defeated last time so um what I'm
trying to say is we should think about
whether we want to be repealing and I
think it was rejected by the Senate last
time so I will ask um the Pres the the
chair um
what is it that you think
is uh an improvement in the language
that you're providing in section in
section one uh a through F that is an
improvement over that very simple
paragraph which covers all of the things
that you're stating about reliability
and uh
affordability well I think the
difference is that this version of a
state energy policy would place the
emphasis on affordability and
reliability which is where it needs to
be not just mention it in passing as the
existing language does I think it's
important for us
to
recognize
that when I go out and and talk to
constituents about electricity
service they do complain to some degree
about the price and the cost of
electricity but mostly what they
complain about is power outages loss of
electricity electrical power that's a
reliability issue and so we have to
design
and policy to protect the reliability of
the supply of electricity and there are
other things that we'd like to do over
and above that but the bottom line is
we've got to make it
reliable and affordable too but uh we
need to emphas EMP iiz that in our state
energy policy can I follow up before I
allow followup I'd like to make a
comment that I've allowed some latitude
but we do need when we question the
testifier we do need to be direct and
answer the question and not a dis ration
leading to a potential question um so
please be brief with your question so he
can ask a question and in the terms of
he may want he may have to answer to
give the information you're that you're
looking for go ahead with the follow
thank you yes I just had a simple
question so how does the bill emphasize
or
improve uh the reliability of energy for
the State of New
Hampshire what we have well the language
of the bill says on line
seven that well Lin 6 seven and 8 that
the state will promote the development
of resources to achieve the purpose of
this chapter without preference to our
technology type with an emphasis on
reliable on demand and firm resources
that is the
definition of electricity that's always
there and that's the definition of
reliable and that's a key component that
we continually seem to lose sight of
when we try to
manipulate uh and
add to our existing
Energy
System ways to create energy that are
not reliable and that uh degrade the
entire systems reliability so we need to
make sure we don't do that because
that's not what people
want repr
Kaplan thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you uh representative o Mr chair for
coming in and representing your bill um
the the statute that you're seeking to
replace on energy policy includes the
affordability and reliability and um but
it also includes other other factors
that this uh this bill would would
sacrifice would would just drop
including you know human health
including the environment uh and so uh
my question is why why do you need to
sacrifice those elements in order to
emphasize affordability and reliability
why why can't we have a balanced
approach which is what I think the state
ought to be pursuing that's just my two
sense well I don't think it does
sacrifice those elements it just places
the emphasis where I feel that it needs
to be and this language um was vetted by
this committee and the house last year
and judged to be worthy of Passage and
so
while I don't think that this language
couldn't be even better and there there
may be some opportunities to make it
better I think this language does what
we need to do to indicate in state
energy policy what really is the Crux of
the
issue
representative
Swanson would you say that uh and I've
given the example before at my home
frequent power
outages and as far as reliability goes
they had nothing to do with the source
of energy and if you have the proper mix
of sources of energy and a well-managed
system you should be able to get
reliability but we didn't have
reliability the problem with reliability
is
infrastructure and that's where the
focus needs to be at are you are you
interpreting reliability to be that the
source of energy has to be always
on yes that is the Crux of the issue the
North American reliability Corporation
in its last three yearly assessments of
the reliability of Our National
Grid they have said that the
encroachment of intermittent renewable
energy sources onto the grid and the
retirement premature retirement
of non-intermittent sources is
jeopardizing the reliability of the grid
and it calls out in its report specc
specific sections of the country that
are particularly vulnerable and the
Northeast is always at the top of their
list so yes the the problem with
renewable energy is that its
intermittency and its lack of backup
resources requires that it be overbuilt
which makes it
expensive but doesn't solve the
reliability issue so if we prefer
renewable resources over non-renewable
resources we get ourselves into a
reliability Crunch and that is slowly
happening and we need to take steps to
make sure that we
arrest that
development representative
rolds thank you Mr Vice chairman
um given given
the
presentations that we had over the last
couple of weeks just really trly were
illustrating
um what we all know about the um
Regional Grid in which you know of which
New Hampshire is a small
part uh and the fact that all of
the generation Assets in the that that
that lie within the state of New
Hampshire the geographic boundaries of
New Hampshire are part of that grid and
yet they don't
you know there's no
particular Authority or uh
physical you know relationship
representative are you thinking of a
question yeah I am I have one there
thanks I said given this and given that
I want to know what you mean by what
you're contemplating by the state's
energy
Independence I mean we're we're
interdependent in a grid and in fact
with six other states because of
interconnection to New York to Quebec
you know the the notion of New
Hampshire's energy Independence I want
to I'm asking what you mean by
that it's a good question and an
important question because as I
indicated in my in the answer to my last
question we are subject here in New
Hampshire
to the activities of our neighbors
surrounding states surrounding regions
the rest of the country even to some
degree and we need to put in place
whenever possible tools
resources that enable us
to do what we can to protect our the
reliability of our own
resources when they are threatened by
the lack of reliability of resources
around us so by energy Independence I'm
talking about giving our state
government tools to resist whenever it
can the encroachment of policies from
surrounding states or other parts of the
country that may negatively impact the
reliability of our grid of of the
state's uh
resources followup thank you Mr Vice
chair um thank you chairman Vose for
that
um my followup is though would would
refer to the entire you know Roman
numeral part two of of the
bill
um again that
these generation assets while they may
reside within the state of New Hampshire
they are private assets and they
operate in the regional market and
there's always a lot of talk here
about wanting the market to guide you
know the mix of resources and prices and
all of it and yet you seem to
contemplate
uh you know the state taking action and
you know the word def end a private
entity it just seems a lot uh I guess
I'm asking what what are you trying to
get at here you're going to see the
state swinging into action to sue the
federal government over should a
generation asset within the state of New
Hampshire become INF feasible in the
market we're going to go to
bat or it in court
yes exactly you may not recall from the
debate on this bill last year but this
portion of the statute from line 24
through to the end is already in statute
the Senate did approve and the governor
did sign that language into law so this
is existing state law whyatt part of
this bill is a you'll have to ask OSS
about that um that was not what I
submitted to OSS but this is what came
back from OS so um the point of that
section two from line 24 on is to give a
generator who is being forced into
premature closure or retirement by
policies uh that probably did not
originate in New Hampshire allows the
generator to approach the department of
energy and possibly even eventually the
Department of Justice to help it defend
itself from that
premature uh
closure okay uh I think we can move on
now thank you so much for a good
testimony I would like to next call on
Katherine corkery from the Sierra Club
New Hampshire chapter Miss corkery
thank you
um my name is Katherine corkery I
represent the New Hampshire chapter of
the Sierra Club it is a pleasure to be
before this committee and um
I am urging the committee to vote itl on
this bill um as we heard from the lead
sponsor this bill was introduced last
year and and the chapter oppos the
language then um because it is confusing
it's contradictory and it does not in
any way address volatile energy
Bills first uh as we heard uh section
Roman 2 I think it is uh is already in
statute um it's really confusing to
repeat statute
um and that section is because it's in
the bill now um is really
problematic as we heard from
representative
rolds it is um it imagines a fictional
Scofflaw power
plant um that would ask and use the
power of the sovereignty of the state to
defend its
illegal
action
um and and it also uh as a a com as a
contradiction speaks of Market
forces how how it provides private
utilities and power generators the
sovereignty of the
state does does that sound like a Market
Force that's really far from Market
Market
forces um and and if you
continue um it also see allows
funding from the legislative fiscal
committee to allow doj
or Department of energy to conduct these
actions so you as as a citizen will be
paying doj to defend a Scuf law power
power
plant that's that's what this bill
says
secondly uh this grouping of Statute is
called part electric utility integrated
distribution
planning why is this
here this has nothing to do with the
distributed distribution planning this
is about regulating
and or deregulating power
plants um we're also uh well there's
also to add to the
confusion uh undefined
terms what is a firm
resource I don't know what that is it
sounds a little mysterious to
me and what is Affordable affordability
is subjective
what is in the federal power act what is
in the
current uh regulations at the Pu is just
and
reasonable that is the bar
now and and it is known and
useful um and and
defendable so and uh lastly this bill is
really unenforced able how do you
enforce this um and and it doesn't have
anything to do to lower energy bills for
granite Staters and I would like to
remind this committee that federal laws
have improved our air and water quality
here in New Hampshire and across the
United States I I uh we know Mercury
comes from power plants and there's a
whole life cycle of
mercury and when it emits from the Smoke
Stack it it
uh interacts with the uh atmosphere and
because it is a metal it's heavy and so
it deposits onto our land and into our
water bodies and when it gets into the
water bodies then it gets into the the
food cycle and the food cycle gets into
us when we eat fish because it
bioaccumulates that means it it builds
up in the bodies of fish and the things
like us that eat
fish then uh accumulate the um the
Mercury and and Wildlife is
not uh excluded from this uh loons who
loves loons I love loons loons will
build up that mercury and
lead and uh other other uh contaminants
and the Clean Air Act and the Clean
Water Act has helped
us lower those impacts investing rather
I think it was uh repr representative
Swanson uh investing in our local
economy to upgrade our energy
infrastructure is time well spent it is
an essential strategy to protect our
Public Safety to protect our public
health and cut down on the future cost
of outdated inefficient
Technologies so I
uh uh support efforts to upgrade our
energy infrastructure with cleaner safer
healthier uh energy sources that can be
paired with battery storage to make it
more more
reliable and uh I I I think wasting your
valuable time on this bill is
misdirected and does it disservice to
your constituents who are who are
struggling with unreasonable energy
rates I ask you to oppose
hp504 thank
you thank you questions for M
Corry representative Summers thank you
Mr chairman and thank you taking my
question um the one part I heard and
that stuck out to me that you stated was
the fact that this bill would be
unenforceable and looking at section uh
Roman numeral 2 I see the department of
energy all the way through this whereas
see the department of energy shall open
an investigator docket to determine how
such an involuntary retirement or
decommissioning would affect the
reliability and affordability of the
state's energy resources and then
secondly the department of energy and
the Department of Justice May seek
funding from the legislative fiscal
committee to conduct any actions
described within the RSA um so this this
looks like an enforcement to me how
would how would you see it as not
they're they're not um I I would argue
um I appreciate the question I would
argue that they're not
enforcing the law they're
enforcing this
so-called involuntary
retirement there this fictional power
plant that is no longer following the
law it allows them to claim that it's
involuntary and um this this is not
enforcement this is about directing
you're directing the department to do
that further
questions representative Kaplan
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss
Corry for coming in today um on the
point of enforcement I I tend to agree
with you that I would love to see a
legal case where the state of New
Hampshire goes up against the EPA to
enforce its to to claim its Sovereign
rights to the energy coming from a a
private generator that's being sold onto
a regional grid but I don't want to talk
about that I wanted to ask you about
your membership and your sense of how
they would feel about a a state energy
policy that would sacrifice human health
and the physical environment in the sake
of emphasizing so-called
affordability thank you for the question
I our membership we have about five
15,000 members and supporters in the
state they are very concerned with the
lack of of um um diversity of energy and
the lack of um energy Choice um what did
we hear Yesterday $20 million
sitting over at do doe not being
Implement implemented as the law in New
Hampshire
allows I or or the Pu pardon me um my
members are very upset about that and my
members are not happy about the
pollution coming for a long time until
unmitigated in our state this is this is
mercury lead dioxin sulfur soot these
are very dangerous pollutants uh to
humans and make matters worse for people
with pre-existing conditions so yes
that's that is definitely what we care
about thank you additional questions for
Miss Corry I know you have limited time
so thank you
oh representative McGee has a question I
was kind of waiting thank you so much
and thank you Miss cery for taking my
question um you were talking a bit about
the nature of the enforcement and all
that and it sounds to me as though the
bill is trying to get us to a place
where we have some way to intercede if
we see a plant that we think provides
reliability uh needs to be uh kept
online but the way it works with the
regional grid isn't it true that the iso
New England is responsible for
reliability so wouldn't the state be
able to go directly to them if somebody
was going to go offline about what the
plans were to try and you know provide
reliability going forward and replace
the plant with whatever else it's going
to be thank you for the question um and
I am no expert but I have lots of
opinions and lots of uh um background um
but I think the reliability question
being on the list the top of the list of
being unreliable is really a question
for ISO New England um this is and um
New Hampshire in particular has the the
least amount of of solar and battery
storage and weatherization and Energy
Efficiency how could it be or let me
pose the question
is it because we have so little solar
and paired with batteries so little
weatherization and and even less Energy
Efficiency programs maybe that's what's
making us unreliable Miss Corry could
you just answer the question and not
engage in a dialogue back and forth I I
can end now so bye okay thank you bye
all right next up we're going to hear
the perspective of the the granite state
hydr Power Association and Miss Heidi
croll will give us her
perspective good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee um for the
record my name is Heidi croll um I work
at um Jay Grimble strategic Solutions
and I'm here today on behalf of the
Granite State hydrop Power Association I
assign in neutral um I was uh happy to
hear um the prime sponsors um comments
when presenting the bill about um uh
perhaps including um some language
around diversity so that was our one
concern was that um the current um
energy policy that we have on the books
um mentions diversity um and this um
draft does not I think it was you know
perhaps an oversight um and we just
think that um diversity does play an
important role in these aspects that are
being discussed around um you know
affordability reliability um security
Independence um and you know health and
safety as well so um I'll be very brief
I'm happy to take questions um but I'm
happy to um you know continue to assist
with the committee um as you look at
potential
amendments your ideas and input is
always appreciated so thank you uh
questions for Miss croll
seeing none thank you we'll turn next to
Meredith Hatfield representing the
nature
conservancy good morning and welcome
back good morning I'm Meredith Hatfield
for the nature conservancy and written
testimony hold this closer thank you uh
written testimony is circular a in I
will also try to be brief um we would
urge you to oppose this bill find it
inexpedient to legislate for the reasons
that I won't read in our letter um
perhaps the most important thing I've
provided to you is the current law um
and thank you to uh representative McGee
for reading it um we think that that
section New Hampshire energy policy in
RSA 378 37 which has been on the book
since 1990 is an elegant expression of
um how New Hampshire has approached
energy issues um really trying to have
it all frankly trying to balance public
health safety our environment as well as
our need for um affordable reliable
energy um as has been mentioned this
bill was um considered last year um and
was rejected by the Senate except for
that one section to that um that
actually is on the books um we really
think this takes us in the wrong
direction ction uh we agree with u Miss
croll from the granite state Hydro
Association that um fuel diversity is
really key to reliability and that
putting all of our eggs in one basket uh
really isn't smart and increasing our
dependence on imported fossil fuels
actually doesn't increase New
Hampshire's energy Independence and
really allowing smaller cleaner more
local energy sources to to continue to
thrive which they've been doing for a
number of years in New Hampshire is
really the course that we we should stay
on um very pleased to hear um chairman
vos's openness to um perhaps considering
some changes to his language um because
we again agree um with Miss croll that
it's extremely important that we
continue to recognize the real value
that um some of our frankly intermittent
resources provide here in New Hampshire
including small Hydro um but also other
clean energy sources that people are
using to actually increase their own
reliability and to weather the storm if
you will um and with that I'd be happy
to take any questions thank you
questions for Miss
Hatfield representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Miss Hatfield
for taking my question as you were
speaking um I uh the thought that came
into my mind was fuel diversity and
costs um people are looking for ways to
uh lower their energy costs and they're
asking us to help them with that and so
I know you have a long history with New
Hampshire and demand side efforts can
you say something about what the role
that demand side plays and also fuel
diversity and costs how they play into
sort of this bill if this bill
would have any effect on that by not
including something like fuel diversity
as a priority for the state yes thank
you for the question sorry for the long
I'll certainly try um so the language in
our current um New Hampshire energy
policy which is on the first page of um
our letter but also is included in the
attachment you know the fact that it
says to maximize the use of cost
effective Energy Efficiency and other
demand side resources really has been
helpful and important um at the Public
Utilities Commission for example and
trying to figure out what is the
cheapest way to meet our energy needs as
a state um and you heard yesterday on um
a different bill you know that the the
meaning of cost-effective efficiency is
that the kilowatt hour of efficiency is
cheaper than the kilowatt hour of supply
and so continuing to allow customers to
take advantage of Energy Efficiency when
it's cheaper than Supply just makes so
much sense you know environment aside
although you know there are significant
environmental benefits as well but it's
just better for customers and as you
mentioned I do have a long history and
you know they say once a consumer
Advocate always a consumer advocate so I
can't help but but but raise that um you
know similarly on the fuel diversity
side in your financial portfolio you
would not invest all of your money in
one company right I mean that just is
pretty broadly I think um considered
that that would be imprudent the same
would be true same is true for energy
you know diversifying our mix and
allowing people to take advantage of new
technology is helpful for all of
us representative Wendy Thomas thank you
Mr chair and thank you Miss headfield
for being here um I realize you wear
many hats one of which is a lawyer so
I'd like to ask you a lawyer question
this is on page two lines six and seven
where it says any act or Omission by a
state agency inconsistent with this
section shall not form the basis of any
civil suit including but not limited to
those seeking Equitable relief or
claiming
damages um that to me and I am not a
lawyer seems to set up a horrifying
situation for public health in New
Hampshire could you please explain the
implications of that of those actions if
we pass
them I'm not sure I can um because as
you say there could be many but I
actually didn't Focus very much on
section two of this bill because it's
already in law um that that was the one
part of uh House Bill 1623 last year
that that did uh pass the Senate was
signed into law and went into effect on
October 1st of last year um but I think
you know you raised some good questions
um you know that could implicate some of
our state agencies so hopefully they're
thinking about that that if they have to
implement this law you know that those
are um things they would have to
consider thank
you seeing no further questions for Miss
Hatfield I want to thank you for
testifying representative Summers you
need to turn off your microphone when
you're not using it thank you okay next
up is um Nick crof from the conservation
law Foundation
hey good morning hello again I'm Nick
cof with the conservation law Foundation
I'm here to testify an opposition to
hp504 um so my my first concern is that
ostensibly the the bill would make it
State energy policy to be
technologically neutral um but then the
bill places an emphasis on reliable on
demand and firm resources and you know B
based on the the chief response from Mr
Chairman's um testimony you this would
mean they would deliberately favor
certain resources um I.E fossil fuels
over other resources um and so that
that's kind of just inconsistent those
those two um Concepts and then the bill
also assumes that affordable reliable
and secure resources you know they're
better for the health safety and Welfare
of the state um but it ignores the
health impacts of traditional fuels like
fossil fuels um which contribute to
asthma and other respiratory illnesses
for our citizens and um you know one
thing I want to point out is that I I
think the language there um could hinder
the state's eventual adoption of small
nuclear um reactor Technologies as um
smrs are currently too expensive to be
commercially viable and so you placing
all the emphasis on affordability could
mean that we don't you know try to
prioritize smrs over the next few years
um you know finally you know this been
mentioned fuel
diversity um as already provided under
the current state energy policy you know
it results in many benefits for the
state um first off renewable energy can
be developed within the state which
reduces our dependence on energy that's
sourced from other countries other
regions of the country and fuel
diversity also makes us less dependent
on fuels with very volatile um prices
and so you know we saw really high
energy prices two Winters ago following
the re War
Ukraine um you know that that was in
large part due to the volatility of of
fossil fuel prices then and so Studies
have shown that more offshore wind would
actually reduce our exposure to
Resources with volatile prices like that
um but you know this bill would depri
deprioritize any efforts to achieve fuel
diversity in our state and then another
point is that the bill seems to assume
that fossil fuels are much more reliable
and dispatchable than other resources
and you know I just want to note that
during winter storm
Elliott um in late
2020 um 2023 I believe or 2022 thanks
several natural gas and oil field power
plants um that are Regional grid
operator ice New England relies on for
dispatch you know they they fail
themselves just showing that you know
some of the resources we assume are more
reliable and dispatchable aren't aren't
often um and then the bill kind of
counts the fact that renewable resources
and especially those with paired with
storage um can provide reliability and
even dispatchability benefits um there
have been studies that show that
increased offshore wind can reduce the
risk of blackouts on a regional Grid in
Winter and then ISO New England has even
found that increased Renewables can um
can resolve winter reliability issues
over the next few years and then just
just finally um I want to note that
Renewables when combined with
storage they're highly dispatchable
probably more dispatchable than
traditional combust combustion um plants
and that you know storage can turn on
real quickly um and you know there's a
storage facility being constructed in
Maine that you know is going to dispatch
the grid 175 megawatts um so storage is
a real viable option there if you
prioritize dispatchability um thank you
very much for your time and happy to
answer any questions and I have handed
out written um written comments as well
that provide more detail thank
you thank you questions for Mr
COV seeing none thank you for your
testimony here this morning thank you
very much next up is John Gage from
wendam thank you Mr chairman and
committee for taking my testimony um
John Gage Windham I oppose this bill I
hope you will too um
I when OSI collected public input for
the state energy policy several years
ago um hundreds of people weighed in
about their wish that the state would
invest in Energy Efficiency clean energy
resources distributed energy resources
and reduce our Reliance on fossil fuels
um I think that public input was pretty
much ignored um when the energy 10-year
energy plan came out uh it focused on uh
the state using the market to decide
what we do um which I'm actually a fan
of um the problem with the current
energy Market is that economists from
around the world say we are currently in
the largest market failure uh in human
history and this failure is the failure
of the energy Market to account for the
costs of the pollution from fossil fuels
and the price of fossil fuels
this failure to have a price signal for
pollution in the energy Market drives
incomplete decisions throughout the
world and it is why we have now
increased the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere by 50%
and why the world has warmed 1 degre
celius already and is on a dangerous
path for much more under the current
policy mix the world is taking action in
putting a price signal for pollution um
there's tools that they can use that are
going to twist the US's armed to do the
same and I think it's dangerous then for
the state to rely on existing Market
forces to make our long-term energy
decisions um we should be anticipating a
future price on pollution a carbon price
at the federal level um
because the experts in climate science
and econom economics say a global price
is required the rest of this Century in
order to meet safe climate goals now the
analysis statement says this bill
revises the state energy policy to
promote affordable reliable and secure
energy resources for the health safety
and Welfare of its citizens I think
what's missing is the word
safe uh is one of the first things that
the energy policy should do should be
affordable reliable safe and secure
energy and and if we had safe energy we
would be accounting for the impacts of
the pollution of our energy choices in
state energy policy By ignoring
pollution um because there's not a price
on it yet we're making short-sighted
decisions the state will lock in to a
more depend on fossil fuels and when
there is a price on pollution from above
we will be stuck with stranded assets so
I agree with the previous speakers that
that say this is um flooded in many ways
um it's internally
inconsistent um saying that we
will allow Market forces to drive things
but then uh we're going to have an
emphasis on reliable on demand and firm
resources and as I understand firm means
fossil fuels or nuclear which is
definitely a important part of our
Energy Mix but if the state is going to
be putting its thumb down in favor of
fossil fuels um because market prices
right now show them to be um preferable
I think that's a mistake we should be
looking at what's happening around the
rest of the world I passed out a
one-pager uh two weeks ago in testimony
of HB 306 titled the growing us carbon
price gap which is my collection of
information that leads me to believe
that a carbon price at the federal level
is coming soon um so please oppose this
Bill thank
you thank you questions for Mr Gage
seeing none I want to thank you for your
testimony
and representative swanman has a
question uh sorry to be slow uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Gage uh
quick question regarding uh the the cost
you're referring to are are you saying
then that despite High startup costs
Technologies offer the potential in the
future for reducing our dependence on
existing Legacy sources and may end up
costing Less in the
future definitely that's the case of
Technology not just of energy but lots
of energy the the government makes
Investments you know whether it's for
space or nuclear or the internet uh
develops a market and then free market
takes over and and puts those things to
to use and and we use them so renewable
energy is in the same curve where we
need to invest in Energy Efficiency and
distributed energy resources now it will
lead to um cheaper energy in the future
follow-up question Mr
chair followup so then would you say
that this bill discourages investments
in new
technologies yes this is I in my opinion
a very backwards looking Bill fossil
fuels were the best energy Choice last
century this Century the leaders of the
next change in h human civilization the
evolution of how we make things better
in the world is clean energy uh and
Energy Efficiency is part of that um we
can use less energy and we can get it
from clean sources protecting our safety
and leading the world and the technology
um of the next change to to drive the
global economy on clean
energy okay seeing no more questions I
want to thank you for your testimony and
we have
uh representative McFarland who would
like to testify
in support of this
[Music]
Bill thank you Mr chairman
representative McFarland from Orange I I
I'm sure you've already heard a lot of
testimony on this bill so I will keep it
brief I'm one of the co-sponsors I
support this bill strongly uh if I know
uh that energy is key to our economy and
that we do not have GDP without energy
and that we have residents in this state
who are struggling to make ends
meet I would urge you to support this
bill as I to pass and I would tell you
that uh fossil fuels are at the moment a
very necessary part of a sensible energy
policy uh happy to Y
questions any questions for
representative
McFarland representative Summers thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
would you agree with the current we were
the testimony oh sorry excuse me uh
disregard that within the testimony that
we've heard today we've heard that it
would have a global economic impact and
with this I I do agree in somewhat
um would you say that a Canada's
Downfall with their economic structure
right now is en tied to the carbon tax
right now where they struggle with their
Canadian dollar impact with the carbon
tax that they're currently struggling
with and is this a main political and
environmental faction that they're
dealing with in Canada you don't have to
answer that because that's not directly
relevant to the
bill are there any other questions
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in representative um in your
opening in your statement just now you
mentioned that fossil fuels are uh
currently right now at the moment uh
the most you know viable fuel source
energy source F I don't think I said the
most I said that they are an essential
part an essential part and I I would
agree with that um especially the right
now part because I think the Energy Mix
is changing if you look at the market
around the country around the world that
that energy mix is definitely trending
towards clean energy uh so how would
this bill protect the state in coming
years against price
instability yeah and I I think it's a
complex question as you all know um I'll
try and narrow the question uh so that
it's something I can answer without
taking the rest of the day on you talked
about the trend towards clean energy I
am very supportive of clean renewable
energy uh such as uh nuclear and we need
uh in the near term to start work on uh
the more than any one legislative
session uh duration of work that is
entailed in bringing uh new investment
into nuclear and uh giving the
confidence to the nuclear energy
companies that they can make those
Investments without seeing them torn out
from under them as we saw from President
Carter
followup yeah I mean sorry with all due
respect you didn't really answer my
question I mean uh how does this bill
could you restate the question yeah how
does this build that which places its
thumb on Legacy fossil fuel
production uh guarantee the state uh
protection against price instability in
coming
years I I think if you look at the
energy policy that's espoused in this
bill uh it represents a balance between
the different things that are necessary
uh and important to the the residents of
this state as I said earlier cost of
living is is a huge issue and I think
that this change to policy uh would be
very beneficial um I I realize that I
you may not think I've answered your
question I I feel that uh it is a
complex question and I know that there
are uh gentlemen around the table here
and ladies who uh understand this deeply
thank you for your answer I appreciate
it thank you okay seeing no more
questions representative sponson has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
Mr McFarland uh quickly uh you mentioned
that you favor nuclear energy but uh my
understanding is that this bill promotes
the cheapest way to go and would nuclear
energy at least as far as a startup
wouldn't that cost a lot more and would
this bill discourage
that yeah great great question and I I
would say to you first of all uh I
support a mix of energy sources I
support a mix of energy sources that is
able to produce a resilient grid uh and
a reliable grid and we need to have
lowcost energy uh I'm not aware that
there is a benefactor who is looking to
subsidize all energy throughout New
Hampshire uh so that we can have
whatever energy sources that that
various people might dream of uh
therefore economics plays a very big
part in that um at the moment fossil
fuels are the most convenient and and
densest and and you know easiest way of
having fuel in your vehicles uh having
fuel for p plants like natural gas based
pea plants uh and nuclear is a very good
solution for Basel load um we have made
changes in this state and are continuing
to make changes uh as a result of our
commitments to ISO New England and to
Reggie uh which are weakening the
reliability of our electricity
generation uh and that is of concern to
me so my the answer to your question is
that my Prime concern is cheap energy
for our constituents and a secondary
concern is achieving reliability in our
grid thank you Mr thank you Mr chair
thank you representative McFarland
appreciate your testimony here today
representative McGee would like to ask
you a question yep thank you you you
tried to get away but thank you for your
time and thank you for your testimony
and I think everyone around the table
shares your concerns as well I mean
that's that's our business here on this
committee I was going to ask whether you
were aware of the statute that this bill
would propose to replace in terms of the
New Hampshire energy policy that it
emphasizes uh the lowest reasonable cost
reliability diversity of energy sources
which we've had testimony here today
people would like to ensure is preserved
because there's a value and U and an
assist in lowering costs and our having
Choice um all of those things uh
reliability cost Effectiveness demand
side resources they're all listed in the
existing energy
policy um so I guess the question is H
how do you see this bill as improving
upon something that we've had
for decades as as our as our general you
know State policy sure well first of all
let me confess to The Honorable lady
that I have read both the existing
statute uh and the bill in some detail
and it's been a few weeks since I read
it so I don't have it on the tip of my
mind but I will tell you that as you
look through the changes that are in
this bill I believe they are changes
that are for the benefit of our
residents and and uh for New Hampshire
in the long
term okay followup followup is there is
there anything specific you can point us
to um I I think I've already said that
one of the most important things from my
point of view is achieving cheap
reliable energy in order to bring down
people's cost of living and in order to
ensure the longevity of our energy
Supply and uh to make sure that we do
not run into systemic issues uh in the
future thank you I don't need to any
further
questions okay thank you appreciate it
and the last word on this bill is going
to go to uh commissioner Chris Elms of
the New Hampshire Department of
energy good morning uh commissioner
welcome good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record Deputy
Commissioner Chris Elms of the New
Hampshire Department of energy uh the
department of energy is neutral on House
Bill 504 but we uh are comfortable with
it and we do have some comments um you
know as you heard sections two and three
are current laws so I'm not going to
spend time on that but would recommend
that the committee consider striking
that from this bill as it's already
State Statute uh the first section of
the bill is a statute is is a rewrite of
the statutory State energy policy and
obviously that is the legislature's
prerogative to dictate uh you know
broadly the state uh energy policy uh
and that helps guide uh the directions
that policy makers and and uh the
executive branch are going to take in
relation to energy policy um and
although the 378 37 statute is not in
and of itself going to be immediately
effectual on any particular program or
funding source there is there are two
Realms within you know the Doe's areas
of responsibility where I will see or
where I will say that there is a an
immediate impact that we would would uh
take into account as you heard in our
intro presentation we have another
statutory mandate under 374 f8 which is
our uh our mandate from the legislature
to our advocate for New Hampshire's
positions regionally and and to Advocate
against uh other states policy decisions
or the shifting of costs of those
decisions uh when they're not in
compliance with New Hampshire's energy
policy so so uh you know obviously what
you do here will impact those directions
and we use that law frequently in our in
our uh conversations collaborations
discussions and negotiations with uh the
other New England states who make up the
ISO New England grid and we point to
this law and say hey we we're here we
have to argue against your policies
because they are not uh in line with
ours so whatever you do here uh it does
impact how we take that the other area
uh within our purview uh where I could
see this being impactful is the uh
update of the 10-year State energy
strategy um you know we are directed to
write that and that obviously does have
impacts on the executive branch
Direction on the energy policy and uh is
used as a resource for legislator and
others in in determining um you know uh
the direction on legislation or uh you
know regulatory proceedings um so that
that would be impactful there and I will
note that we currently have open a
comment period uh for the the next
update of the 10-year strategy uh we I
don't think have had any comments as as
of yet so we're we're looking forward to
those and then obviously uh per the
statute we will we will be uh asking the
chairman to uh invite us to to uh meet
with this committee as as is required by
law uh on the 10year state energy
strategy so this bill's policy statement
certainly is a more clear uh Direction
than what we have under current 378 37
uh the current policy statement is
pretty broad as you've heard it's it's
it's mostly a list of uh of good things
and and it's a direction that we should
sort of balance all these all these uh
considerations and that's that's great
right uh but it isn't all that helpful
in determining a direction because it's
essentially just saying do good things
and don't do bad things and uh I think
that this bill um certainly does give us
a more Clear Vision and a statement of
emphasis on reliability and
affordability as the prime sponsor uh
mentioned uh it emphasizes Market
principles it's focused on markets and
not government driving resource
selection and limiting subsidization
only to what's necessary um
yeah I'm happy to take questions you
you've heard the whole the whole thing I
will say I guess up front uh there's
been a lot of discussion on technology
neutrality and and sort of an all of the
above strategy and and I had mentioned
it in the intro presentation that we
gave a couple of weeks ago but I will
mention here that technology neutral
doesn't mean you can't have goals right
having a goal of reliability of
affordability of Environmental
Protection whatever it might be those
are perfectly with reasonable in a
technology neutral State and in fact
they're they're encouraged what what you
want with technology neutrality is to be
goal oriented so we say what do we want
the outcome to be and then from there we
we can select the resources that will
help us meet that what technology
neutral means is we're not going to
Advantage a particular technology or
disadvantage of particular technology
simply by virtue of it being that
technology right we we want to know what
we want to do and then and you know
build the system to uh meet it so happy
to take questions
okay uh questions for commissioner Elms
representative
kapan I'll defer to represent McGee as
as my ranking member representative
McGee thank you that's very kind of you
to see again hand first sorry good to
good to see you again uh Mr Elms so uh
or Deputy Commissioner Elms right that
correct um You referred to 374 f8 as a
location where you're required to to um
protect the interests of the state in
the region uh and any Regional policies
that affect us internally would that not
already give you jurisdiction if there
was something on the regional grid that
was located within the state this
conversation's come up already um if
there were a power plant that
were uh affected that you wanted to
discuss in terms of reliability for the
state even though it's a regional grid
wouldn't you
already have the authority to go to um
you know the iso New England and discuss
with them any plans for retirement or
conversion or that sort of thing it it
just doesn't seem like this bill really
has that much purpose except to
overwrite what you know the statute that
exists which I think many of us feel has
been helping us have better policies
because it is all inclusive in terms of
the the things that it includes right
now yeah Don thank you for the question
I'm sorry I have a four-month-old at at
home so I might just be I'm not sleeping
great so uh uh what what I would say is
is that question sort of directed to
sections two and three and sort of that
responsibility
to uh you know uh okay yeah it's
existing law you know I guess from from
our perspective if if this bill
contemplates striking that law we'd be
happy to provide more comments um that's
in effect it hasn't been used that that
uh ability we haven't heard from a power
plant if it were to happen we would
obviously follow the statute and work
with the doj to determine what if any
actions we would take um I I think you
know the doj and certainly the
department of energy uh do have
capabilities with this law and without
this law to Advocate on behalf of New
Hampshire's policy and interests in the
federal and Regional
levels follow up so the followup would
be then you had mentioned that you
thought that this version of the New
Hampshire energy policy
was more specific and easier better
defined and easier to follow so I'd like
to know what you think particularly is
better about this gotcha no no that
that's a that's a good question too and
so on on that realm it's more um when we
look at our discussions in at Nesco um
the New England states committee on
electricity and that's where we uh get
together with the states to figure out
recommendations that we're going to make
as the states to ISO New England and the
broad group of stakeholders um you know
a lot of times those conversations are
centered on things like Market design
for how we procure wholesale energy and
uh you know a lot of those uh Market
design questions are pretty complex and
they're involve uh the balancing of the
variety of States policy goals and so in
those
conversations um you know New Hampshire
we we take the line that we want to
promote New Hampshire's policies so to
the extent that those policies direct us
that our preference is for
um you know Market selection of
resources as opposed to you know power
purchase agreements as opposed to other
sort of out of Market actions to the
extent that uh our state policy directs
us to be fuel neutral when it comes to
Resource selection uh all those things
will come into play in our discussions
with with other folks because if this
state energy policy rewrite was to say
simply you know we want to focus on
decarbonization uh as as New Hampshire
priority in there
uh we're going to take a very different
position than we would if the if the
preference is for affordability or
reliability um and and so you know in
those discussions that's where a
statement uh comes into play again
neutral whether or not this statement is
is the pref the preference that's up to
the legislature to determine uh I'm just
trying to let you know how we will take
what you do and use that uh in in the
furtherance of our mission
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
and thank you commissioner Elms for
coming in
um I forgot I was gonna say
um oh yeah okay um can we go to
representative Bry while no I've got the
question uh regarding the the first
section of the bill and and the uh the
uh the emphasis on on reliable and firm
um it seems to be premised on the idea
that that the regional uh Market actors
are acting irresponsibly or heading in
some sort of Reckless Direction so
what's your sense as somebody as as you
just mentioned interacting at that level
is are the regional you know actors ISO
New England the um the other people uh
are they taking care of are they
cognizant of of these concerns and are
are those concerns being h heard it's a
good question thank you for it um you
know I'm not sure I'm I'm quite at the
place where I could use the word
reckless but uh no obviously there are
real concerns they've been raised as as
uh I think representative o raised uh
from nerk uh and and ISO New England as
we talked about in their epet report uh
in our intro presentation that's the uh
uh report where they talked about sort
of what would be needed to meet the
decarbonization goals of New England by
2050 and obviously there's going to be a
lot of infrastructure needed if we're
going to meet the goals um of New
England while maintaining the policy
directions that the various states have
um you know from from from our
perspective there are real reliability
challenges uh we're spending a lot of
time working on them uh we're spending a
lot of discussion on them but there are
some real uh difficulties in imagining
how we are going to maintain the system
we have with the electrification goals
that folks have without some type of
large scale infrastructure infusion
somewhere whether it's in a particular
resource um or in in other
infrastructure or or or simply just you
know Finding ways to insulate ourselves
from the from those goals if we don't
think it's going to be possible and I
know there's other legislation to look
at
that followup follow yeah so I'm just
curious about the word insulate and and
because that's kind of echoed in this
bill
what would those measures entail to
insulate ourselves from the
regional well I believe representative
Summers has introduced a bill that would
uh instruct the department of energy to
investigate what that could look like uh
whether it's looking at uh completely
leaving ISO New England's grid as a
state or to explore other regulatory or
policy decisions that would would uh you
know examine whether or not our
participation in ISO Regional markets is
uh in the best interests of New
Hampshire so there there are a variety
of things I could look at I'm certainly
not ready to tell you all of them and
and that's actually something that we
would be instructed to look into and to
provide reports back uh to this
committee and to the legislature broadly
uh should other legislation move forward
representative bne has a question thank
you chairman and thank you uh
commissioner els for um
testifying um so there's been a lot of
questions and answers implying that this
bill strongly favors fossil fuels um but
uh lines uh 10 through 12 talk about um
the state's energy Independence and I
was wondering how does the department of
energy interpret ensuring the state's
energy Independence and then later in
the same sentence uh it talks about
secure energy resources does does secure
energy resources and energy Independence
exclude fossil fuels includes them or
how does that um compare with locally
produce resources I guess that's a
that's a very good question
representative thank you very much for
it and I was uh saying to my colleague
before I came up that uh I know there
was a lot of talk about fossil fuels in
the bill I couldn't find the reference
to it and maybe it was just sort of the
unanimous agreement that that fossil
fuels you know fall into that sort of
more reliable uh and affordable energy
source you know that certainly wasn't my
reading up front uh you know as we said
we viewed it to be goal oriented and so
if fossil fuels are the
best means of achieving our goals great
if solar and storage is the best means
of doing it that's great we want to make
sure we we meet the goals with whatever
we can as efficiently as cheaply and as
uh you know uh stably as possible um you
know to to the question about energy
Independence I think it's a good one and
one where you could uh certainly read
different parts of it and and I think
you know maybe maybe Clarity might be
helpful there um and we've you know uh
looked at that
I think to me looking at energy
Independence in the context of State
energy policy uh as I talked about
before um looking at sort of insulating
ourselves from the policy decisions of
folks at the regional and federal level
it was what I looked at there you could
read into it other directions and I
think that would be perhaps helpful
Clarity um uh should this bill you know
move
forward follow up um and then the the
second uh question was about secure
energy resources how do you interpret
secure in that in that uh line it's the
it's the same line uh sentence but the
last last uh two three
words yeah so uh you know there there
are a whole uh number of ways that you
could interpret secure resources you can
look at supply chain security when you
look at something like you know our
natural gas infrastructure is ryant on
for the most part on Pipeline capacity
so you know to the extent that that that
gets eaten up and that we have a a
lacking in in appropriate pipeline
capacity that that's a security concern
there's also obviously supply chain uh
in relation to other resources um and
then obviously cyber security is
something that could could play a role
there ensuring that we have a resilient
grid uh you know in a in a place that
obviously has a lot of weather effects
so you know you could read into a number
of things I think you know all of it
comes back to the idea of reliability
again if you're being goal oriented
right customers want to be able to flip
the switch and turn the lights on and so
building out from that is how you can
look at reliability to make sure okay is
what we're doing ensuring the
functioning of the grid and and
maintaining uh you know our ability to
to provide electric service to our
customers representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner Elms
uh before I retired a couple years ago I
was a group leader for Global navigation
satellite system
modernization and it was critical for us
to have measures remember we need to ask
a question reliability and
availability and those measures had
formulas and thresholds you mentioned a
uh 10-year energy strategy uh there's no
formula or thresholds in this bill but
in your 10 10e energy strategy do you
have formulas or thresholds for
reliability and
availability uh there there certainly
are reliability standards that are
placed and a lot of the times that's at
the sort of the iso New England uh level
and that's you a lot of times based on
expectations for outages or load
shedding and and and you know the
ability to say we are going to maintain
service with the exception of one one
day every 10 years or whatever the
standard uh is so there are standards
I'm I'm sorry I don't have them off the
top of my head and I can certainly uh
you know follow up with the committee
and talk about some of those reliability
standards that exist thank you
commissioner Els thank you Mr chair
thank you representative M thank you for
indulging me and you as well um I just
had the a question you mentioned that
the 10year energy strategy report had o
Open time for public comment can you
just tell us when that's done because I
would like to comment if I
could uh we think the end of March uh
it's on our website and we can happily
follow up with the committee to give you
that timeline and we'll we'll intend to
keep pushing that out uh so that folks
can have their voices
heard okay great so let's oh come
on representative
Corman okay he waves off so we're done
on this house bill uh so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
because we need to open a public hearing
on House Bill 508
FN relative to decreasing assessment
rates for entes providing Voiceover IP
and IP enabled Services as well as
certain local exchange carry carriers
and their Affiliates and so I'm going a
call to the table testimony table the
Bill's Prime sponsor representative
Harrington to introduce this legislation
good morning um this bill is is is sort
of a u i I might call it a hangover bill
from the times of old regulations that
no longer exist uh we have companies
that are paying fees to the Public
Utilities Commission that used to be
regulated by the Public Utilities
Commission but now they're not and the
idea was you know that like an electric
utility now pays in a certain percentage
to fund the Pu
so that the the cost of the regulation
came from the people being regulated but
in the case of these companies and the
speaker will come after me can go into
much more detail they are no longer
regulated we don't regulate VoIP we
don't regulate uh IP enabled uh Services
we don't regulate any of that stuff uh
there's basically no regulations left on
phones uh with the exception of a very
very slight amount but it's almost
negligible and what this bill does is
simply takes the assessment that they
were paying of3 3 3% and drops it to 10%
so like I say I'll defer to someone who
can ask specific questions on it or
answer specific questions on it but
that's basically the intent of the bill
it's just to bring us up to the reality
of the fact that we're charging
companies to pay for regulation that
they no longer a part of okay well I do
have to ask you one question sorry but
it just kind of jumped out at me on line
three the number 33 has changed to 10%
to 10
but online 4 33
is um repeated should that be change to
10 or or are we talking about two
different things there
um I would think it should be but I'll
let the the next speaker address that
specifically okay okay thank you any
other questions for representative
Harrington good because I wasn't going
to answer them anyway seeing none I'd
like to call next on Teresa
Rosenberger and Chris
row representing
nhta I assume you guys want to testify
together welcome nice to see you
both thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
Chris Rand I am vice president of
Granite State
Communications uh here representing the
members of the New Hampshire telephone
Association and HTA is composed of
internet and voice providers serving
some of the most rural areas of New
Hampshire uh the companies within NTA
are Breton Woods telephone Dunbarton
telephone my company Granite State
Communications and the TDS
companies nhta provides uh nhta
companies
provide internet and voice service to
mostly rural areas and are mostly fiber
uh we're very close to 100% fiber
coverage uh the nhda members have been
deregulated since
2011 and in that time we've seen our
interactions with the Public Utilities
Commission dwindle to almost none today
the puc sends two filings to the FCC on
our behalf and receives the occasional
uh Consumer
complaint uh looking back over the last
5 years for my company in particular uh
over those years we've received two
complaints uh through the Pu related to
customers uh in 2011 the law that
deregulated all of us also moved
consumer complaints uh under the purview
of the Attorney General and we've not
received any complaints from
them one stipulation of the 2011
deregulation includes limits on the
frequency and the magnitude ude of
increases to basic telephone service
which is simply dial tone service
nothing
else by Design the pu's
responsibility for reviewing those
pricing changes expired after eight
years today the Pu is working on the
save the 603 numbering effort uh this
docket marks a shift to assessing docket
participants rather than relying on the
mandatory annual assessment this means
that the nhta companies are actually
paying twice our annual assessment and
the invoices related to this specific
docket we feel that by reducing the
level of annual assessments nhta
companies we'll have additional funds
available to direct towards completing
our fiber networks and also conver
converting customers to those
networks given these facts we maintain
the traditional assessment level is UN
necessary and moving from 33% to 10%
better reflects the funding level
necessary to support telecommun modern
telecommunications
oversight uh now we are not seeking to
eliminate the assessment only to reduce
them to a level that reflects the pu's
reduced oversight of the
Telecommunications
industry okay thank you questions for
did you have something to add Miss Ros
murder oh yes I do thank you may I move
this so I can see Representative no you
can't I'm sorry but um all right we've
been told in no uncertain terms that the
only people who can move that equipment
are the house audio visual staff right
I'll sit up we can call them and have
them come down and move it if you like
no I just feel like I'm ignoring but
I'll sit up so I can see um thank you
very much I'm Teresa Rosenberger from
Bernstein Shore I'm here representing
with Chris New Hampshire telephone
Association which is all the landline
old mobel companies and Consolidated
Communications and thank you
representative Vose you are correct the
language we sent to um representative
Harrington and he sent to OS did have
that other 33% change to
10 so you are correct on
that so thank you thank you thank you
and thank you representative Harrington
and sumers for sponsoring this bill as
you've heard it's a very simple Bill
deregulation went into effect in
2012 now we are 12 years later and the
assessments went down back in
2016 but we still are being assessed um
we believe at a rate that's not
comminate with the services we're
receiving so what I did did and the
reason I'm here with Chris is because I
ped all the members some of the
information is confidential so you get
me for that information and as Chris
said yes everybody does filings to the
FCC it's the high cost calf filings that
go through the department of energy um
people have had and and what I let me
back up and say I asked them to give me
a five-year look back so I asked them to
go back back to
2018 or 19 so they all do the filings
twice a year they go to the FCC they go
they submitted to the Pu own
complaints basically people aren't
getting any complaints it's you know as
Chris said in his case it was somebody
wanting service in a certain section of
wear or um somebody calling and saying a
double cable was down but basically the
complaints going from the AG's and
through the AG's office and nothing's
coming through they do get emails uh if
there is a uh rules change if the rules
being changed and going to jail car
they'll send an email and say the rules
are being changed here's the draft um
they get the um they file the annual
interestate 71 access rate
filings and one company in 5 years had
two interconnection agreement
requests and what was interesting about
that is they never heard from the Pu
that it was done and so they only found
out that it had been approved by going
onto the
docket now there are other issues out
there which you know about dual pulse
way back and I forgot the bill number
Senate Bill 16 or Senate Bill something
anyway there's a bill years ago on
double polls coming out of Rochester and
since
2023 that has been worked on at the Pu
with the stakeholder grip so it's been
all of the pole owners including
electric and Telco working on removing
double poles and as I understand it the
pilot is starting in February so that is
nearly over
um for a Consolidated they sold their
poll to ever source and that went before
the Pu and it went P before the Pu
specifically because they were being
sold to an electric which is a regulated
utility so that was done and completed
uh
consolidated sold their assets they did
a merger with
Starlight um there was one hearing that
did go before the Pu and it was a very
fat fast quick and very successful uh
outcome now what we get to go what's
going forward the 603 area code and
that's the rate Center
consolidation that is going forward but
you passed a bill last year that allows
the Pu to assess all folks who have the
603 area code who are in that docket a
special assessment which is what Chris
is talking about double taxation there
the other um Bill you passed last year
Senate Bill
595 which having to do with the raate
attachment disputes uh that you also are
allowing a separate assessment so where
we're coming here and a lot of the
things that are being the special
assessed are under the department of
energy not the Pu so there's kind of a
question from us about why are we paying
an annual assessment to the Pu when a
lot of this is actually working with the
OE and I think it's because of the the
the conversion of that of the department
um so for us when we look at I've got
the report here which is Blink thing uh
utility assessments and when you really
look at it on the Telco side most
carriers of VoIP and with that they
means you're paying $1,000 a year now my
guess is three to five years everybody
will probably be vo so everybody be
paying that but it seems at this point
it would be prudent to when I've named
what really is going on which is these
annual filings any complaint that may
come that really a 10% assessment would
be sufficient it seems to make sense
that and and as I think we've talked
about this is not reducing the puc
budget what it's doing is assessing
those who are using their
Services uh more fairly so it's not a
budget decrease it's not having staff
fired or any of that or let go um it's
literally saying if most of your work is
electric they should be assessed or
water or gas but let's just do it let's
do it in a way that makes sense for
everybody and for the companies for them
it's money that can be put into
Broadband I mean we all as you heard me
last week here with the the bill on uh
copper or Fiber everybody's working as
hard as they can to get to 100% And we
need the capital to do it so we should
be able to take that and give it to the
people who deserve it and not paying for
services that we're not really receiving
I'd be happy to answer any
questions so I have a question thank you
very much for for testifying if the p is
over
assessing the companies that you
represent what are they doing with that
extra money do you have any
idea no because because we're not
hearing from them the companies I mean I
you know I pulled all the companies on a
joint call and then I called each one
separately and said what go back I want
you to go back and look for your emails
I want you to call the people who pay
the assessment I want you to hit
everybody in your company that could
have interaction and I'd like to know
what it is
and it's
minimal except for except for I will say
that's for everybody except for
Consolidated and as I did say
Consolidated had the merger which
clearly their assessment of
$300,000 or more was paying for that per
year um and Consolidated certainly did
have the pole sale and but those are
done so you know at this point there's
nothing really to pay for that they
can't assess us for in a special
assessment and let me say the companies
I don't know whether Chris has but a
number of the companies in nhca have
already been assessed for the 603
special assessment for the 603 area
coach special
assessment so can we assume that the
lack of a pu objection to this bill
means that they're fine with
it well I would hope hope they're fine
with it yes I mean I I would I would
hope so I did speak with them and
explain what why we were doing this and
explain that we really weren't getting
much service and when you look at it
it's still you're still getting 10% of
all the revenues of the so it's not as
if they're not getting some still some
good money that should cover what I call
the
administrative cost of sending in the
invoice for the for the special
assessments or the assessments and the
filings with the
FCC okay thank you representative Corman
has a
question thank you but um my ranking
member had her hand up and I would defer
to
her representative McGee has a question
Mr chair I did not instruct my committee
to defer to me but it's very nice that
they are my question was really what the
difference in the money is if we could
get a sense of that you've thrown out a
couple of numbers but we can't sort of
determine whether it's an impact or not
um we have I I guess you know we don't
know what percentage of the Pu budget it
would represent but we can say we have
33% versus 10% so what are you asking
for versus what what is it
today excuse me sorry I accidentally
turned off your mic that's okay I'm GNA
give you round numbers that I pulled out
from the assessment and it will include
um it will include the cable folks com
cast time water Etc and this bill does
include them this bill is not just for
the Mel companies it's for for the the
whole whole shebang of the telephone and
um have the figures just for yeah who
you were here representing other than oh
would you want me to give you just who
give me what you're talking about as
long as I know what's in well you know
for for the nhta companies we're
probably talking about well let me say
the NHC and the comcs companies we're
probably talking about
$400,000 maybe maybe a little more or a
little less depending on what this next
year is going to be and so I figure with
that you're still going to be it's 33%
down to 10% you're still going to be
probably $140
$150,000 which which is why I'm thinking
that's perfectly fine for for the
administrative cost particularly when uh
the 603 and what you heard about Pol T
but those by law can be special
assessed follow up you did mention that
you didn't think any jobs would be lost
but if there's sort of a 20 and
something it's a very small staff at the
Pu at this point so I guess the question
is how do you draw that conclusion I
draw that conclusion because the way the
statute um reads and I can pull it up
here in a minute tell you uh where the
statute reads is um
the expenses thus not this is print
small ascertained shall be assessed
against the public utilities and other
entities described in this section so
their assessment is against all public
their expenses are waged against all
public utilities that they regulate and
as they say the um the the others
described in this section which is VoIP
and Telco and the co-op because the
co-op op vo um Telco Cable telephone and
and the co-op are
33% and everybody else is 100% so it's
just the cost will get spread of their
expenses under the people who are are
the companies that are receiving the
services actually I've heard that before
thank you yeah well it's it's conf
believe me it's confusing thank you okay
now representative Corman I actually had
the same question as representative
McGee
then you should have asked it okay
representative Thomas thank you and I
also had the same question um but I had
a
followup um I actually think this is um
this appears to be a good bill and um it
it kind of makes sense to me um what I
would like to know is there any
assurance that the savings that would
that would come as a result of this bill
would be invested in uh
efforts for public or member benefit and
that they wouldn't go to a CEO or
anything like that do you want to take
that or you want me to take it you take
it for you and then I'll take it for the
rest of the group uh in a word yes um
each company is required to certify that
the money that they're receiving each
year is going to essentially building
Broadband uh and not funding CEO
salaries so I know for our company we
would you know know for every dollar
that we can't put to broadband means
customers don't get connected so the
looking back over this uh the years uh
when we have not been regulated probably
if you took all of the households around
this table and doubled it that's the
equivalent of people who would not have
been connected to the network so it
doesn't mean people don't get connected
it just means that they're pushed off so
a reduction in these costs cost simply
allows us to pull those jobs forward and
connect more people
faster and I think that is true for all
of the companies and and because they
all are totally committed to getting to
that 100% plus it's a competitive
Marketplace so you want to hit as many
people as you can so you can serve them
followup H
up sorry um so in your opinion would
this um reduction in how much is paid
lead to the creation of jobs in New
Hampshire you take it potentially um
were we to have more funds to connect
customers to broadband we certainly
would there could be an opportunity
based on how much of a reduction in
expenses there are there's a potential
that we could hire additional installers
purchase more equipment and get those uh
customers connected faster so there
definitely is a potential yes thank you
there's there's also the the potential
that when you connect those customers
they may well all of a sudden have jobs
as well you may when you connect people
they may be able to work particularly
those in the area the rural areas so
thank you for the
question representative M thought of
another question I did and the question
is if the the uh expenses of the Public
Utilities Commission are distributed
amongst everybody else and you guys get
a discount how much does that affect
them I'm just think we should have the
whole picture before
we it it should be by exactly the same
amount but I'm just saying what is it
distributed over in terms of what kind
of an impact that will be
to that's a good question for them I'm
assuming we're talking about somewhere
around
$250,000 which and I'm assum assuming
that probably the majority of their
works on the electric side and um but it
would be distributed between the
electric gas and water utilities so I'm
not sure how much that difference that
would make because I don't know how many
customers I hope the Pu can they may be
able to tell you but thank
you all right representative Summers
thought of a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and I I was actually really I
was very happy and excited to actually
co-sponsor this bill and the qu
questions just I had real quick and it
might go along with the RSA or even
possibly future administration of it but
I noticed it mentions just the Lex the
local exchange carriers with the
capability of Corporations be able to um
create and with Hardware software be
able to create and add and subtract
their own VoIP would it be possible to
think that all bar Broadband Services
all cre
vo services and therefore would fall
under
this I'm not familiar enough I'm not
familiar enough with all the aspects of
the current
RSA uh I believe there are a long list
of truly VoIP providers yeah providing
service in New Hampshire and this
applies to a small group who are being
assessed at a much higher rate than all
of those other vo providers who from my
view of the list pay about $ thousand
dollar a year the the vo providers the
list the Pu puts out there's it's broken
into Telco and vo and the vo providers
are paying $11,000 a year the statute
says that the for registration and the
minimum you pay is
$1,000 and so the vo providers are doing
that and if if you change from to being
a VoIP is $1,000 but the tel codes are
the ones that are uh applied in this
statute which is pretty much the
landline funds and the cable providers
thank
you okay seeing no more questions we
would like to thank you both for
testifying and call on the last person
who wants to testify
representing the agency that was um
supposed to produce the fiscal this U
legislation Megan Stone from the
Department of
energy good uh morning again miss
Stone good morning Mr chair good morning
members of the committee um so I
apologize uh I have a letter coming to
you today that has a lot of this
information in it um but I do have some
information that I think can help
address some of the questions that just
came up um so that is what I have for
you today the department is neutral on
this bill um so the department currently
assesses all regulated utilities and
other and certain other utilities
including accepted local exchange
carriers vo providers and providers of
Ip enabled service for the expenses of
the Pu and the expenses of the
non-federally funded functions of the
department supporting its regulatory
obligations as well as expenses of the
office of the consumer
Advocate um the current assessment inv
voices to expected local exchange
carriers and certain vo providers and
providers of Ip enabled Services um are
based on 30 33% of gross utility revenue
and this bill reduces that to uh 10%
gross utility revenue it does not change
the minimum um assessment of
$1,000 so for fiscal year 25 the
department assessed and I'll give you
exact numbers
529,000
to dollar to 26 accepted local exchange
carriers out of 171
providers um if the assessment had been
based on 10% of gross utility revenues
the assessment would have been
$158,600 would have instead been
collected as part of the assessment
invoices paid by other regulated
utilities gas electric water and sewer
um and the assessment costs are
recovered by other regulated utilities
through the rates charged to customers
um in my letter that I'll send you there
is a wide range of Duties supporting
telecommunication providers that are
covered by the assessment funds um and
just I I would just give you a couple of
them but I have I have quite a few um
and that includes registration of new
telecommunications providers review of
daily requests for numbering resources
um encompassing analysis of available
resources in requested rate centers
identification of blocks of numbers held
by other providers solicitation of
donations to the pool coordination of
the transfer of number numbering
resources among carriers uh and there's
quite a few other things so I will give
you the whole list that I have um I am
happy to take uh any questions may have
our experts can be available today to
testify on this but um anything I can't
answer I can take back to the department
and make sure you
get okay thank you
so if we reduce the assessment on these
this particular class of carriers will
that increase the assessment on other
carriers is that what I yes heard you
say yes okay thank
you further questions for the Department
of energy
well seeing none I guess uh you're done
thank you and so are we so that
concludes the public hearing on House
Bill
FN and because
our our proceedings went a little long
this morning I'm going to exercise my
Chairman's prerogative of restarting the
1:00 public hearing at 1:15 so we'll
have adequate time to do lunch and take
care of other issues that members may
have to deal with so we will resume our
activity at
1:15 see you
then
e
e e
testify I need a pink card from you
please thank
you e
okay good afternoon everyone and welcome
to the afternoon session of science
technology and energy for January 28th
two public hearings on the docket for
this afternoon the first one is HB 535
FN relative to defining the role of the
Public Utilities Commission that will be
followed by
hp450 relative to commercial property
assessed clean energy and
resiliency called C
Pacer so we'll open the public hearing
first on House Bill
535 and in the absence of the Bill's
Prime sponsor who is is busy introducing
another bill somewhere else I'm going to
call on representative Dale Swanson to
introduce House Bill
535 good afternoon
representative don't forget to turn on
the
mic thank you Mr chair uh thank you
members of the committee and uh the
folks attending here um this this is to
introduce Bill 53 House Bill
535-nm minates certain grants of
authority to the Public Utilities
Commission and requires in any contested
case before the commission to which the
department of energy and the office of
the consumer Advocate are parties the
commission to approve by order any
settlement agreement to which all
parties are a signatory unless the
commission determines after hearing that
any settlement provision is contrary to
the law this bill is at the request of
the office of the consumer Advocate uh
you can ask me questions but uh I'll
probably not be as familiar with it as
some of the folks who are attending here
and uh I'll defer to them when
necessary okay so repres representative
Swanson has indicated that he would
prefer not to take
questions that okay with everybody looks
like it is representative so thank you
for introducing this bill and someone
who I know will gladly take questions is
our consumer Advocate Donald Cree so I'm
going to call him next to testify on
this
legislation uh thank you Mr chairman
good afternoon to everybody thank you
for the opportunity to testify I am
Donald Cree I am the consumer Advocate
my job pursuant to RSA
36328 is to represent the interests of
residential utility customers uh in a
surfit of caution I feel obliged to
disclose that the testimony I am about
to give is going to refer to three open
Public Utilities Commission dockets and
that may have implications for RSA 363
section 12 paragraph
3 uh as representative Swanson indicated
I uh proposed this bill and
representative Corman was kind enough to
introduce it on my behalf as consumer
Advocate I care about two things safe
and reliable service at the lowest
possible cost and maximizing consumer
Freedom by giving rate payers the agency
they need to use energy and water as
they see fit particularly as relates to
the affordability prong utility
regulation in New Hampshire is in my
respectful opinion not not working right
now and this ineffectiveness is costing
rate payers a lot of money because every
cent of the cost of regulating Utilities
in New Hampshire is recovered from
customers via utility
assessments now I have to say that my
intentions here have been widely
misunderstood when I floated a
preliminary version of this bill uh by
the residential rate payers Advisory
Board which is the statutory advisory
body to my office back in in October
that produced an intemperate letter from
chairman goldner and commissioner chadow
Podi and it all got kind of personal I
really regret that because the point
here is not to criticize any of my
fellow human beings it is rather simply
to remind everyone of something that was
acknowledged and understood in July of
2021 actually I think it was June of
2021 that is when the department of
energy was created and the Public
Utilities Commission was downsized and
reconfigured Ed via that Year's Budget
Trailer bill it was a hasty process
undertaken at the very end of a
legislative session and it was
understood by everybody that the
enabling statutes of the two agencies
would have to be re-examined based on
experience well four years later here is
what experience suggests these two
agencies need more specific legislative
direction to the effect that the
department of energy is the policy shop
and the Pu 's job is to act more or less
the way a court acts as a neutral
decision maker when the interests of
utility shareholders and the interests
of utility customers need to be balanced
against each other right now the two
agencies seem to be talking past each
other let me give you a couple of very
recent examples from pending rate cases
first is the Liberty electric rate case
doc at De
23039 the proceeding turned into a
fiasco when in the fall of 2023 the
Department's audit revealed that the
books and records of the utility the
basis of the whole rate case were
unreliable this is what happens my
friends when a utility transitions from
one billing and accounting system to
another in the middle of the test year
that is used to calculate the utility's
revenue requirement the department filed
a motion to dismiss the rate case more
than a year ago which the Pu for
whatever reason has not acted upon
excuse
me uh anyway uh the department filed a
motion to dismissed the rate case more
than a year ago the Pu hasn't ruled on
it meanwhile the parties which is to say
the utility the department and our
office seeing no good outcome succeeded
in negotiating a settlement agreement
The Proposal basically maintains the
status quo until 2026 when Liberty will
file the new rate case but when the
settlement came before the Pu for a
hearing a few weeks ago the
Commissioners made their distaste for
the agreement plain they looked at the
department and said you told us the
books and records were unreliable so how
can you now claim that the rates you
have agreed on will be just in
reasonable well here's why because every
other alternative risks sending this
utility into insolvency and an insolvent
utility is bad for shareholders and bad
for customers another example is the
pending eversource rate case do de
2470 this one's a bit more prosaic it's
a big complicated case the Pu allowed
the parties including the department of
energy to Wrangle for months about the
procedural schedule given the statutory
deadline that looms this coming may we
finally agreed on uh this past Friday as
the big day the day everyone other than
eversource would file their written
testimony and then a couple of weeks ago
the department decided it couldn't meet
the deadline so the department asked for
an extension the Pu said no and the
department basically ignored the
deadline leaving most of its testimony
unfiled to this day a bigger example
from last year is the commission's net
metering dock at De
22060 the parties reached a settlement
the Pu didn't reject the settlement the
commissioner simply ignored it in spite
of broad consensus among the utilities
my office and those who unlike me are in
love with net
metering so I cob P together my best
ideas for how to fix things statutorily
but my main purpose is is to incite
dialogue here at the state house I'm not
trying to make myself King and I am
certain others who are smarter than me
can think of approaches that would be
even better than the ones I've suggested
including tweaks to the language about
settlement agreements because I just
want this process to work to meet the
needs of all
stakeholders this could I suppose turn
into a suicide mission there's serious
talk here at the State House of
abolishing my whole office but for me
it's a matter of conscience the
utilities won't ever speak out in favor
of a bill like this utilities never do
anything that might seem like criticism
of their regulator I get that I know all
of the key deciders over at the Walker
building all of them are good people who
come to work every day striving to do
the right thing they just need what was
promised to them four years ago more
clarity from the general court about
what they are supposed to do and how
they're supposed to do it uh that
concludes my prepared testimony of
course I'd be happy to answer any
questions that the chairman might be
willing to
entertain thank you Mr chis we
appreciate that testimony I do have a
couple of questions for you in the bill
on page two lines 5 through
n there is new text describing the
authority of the commission
and it says that the commission can
conduct contested
adjudicative
proceedings uh within the meeting of RSA
541 etc etc
etc and it also can adopt administrative
rules Etc but it doesn't say anything in
here about whether the commission could
undertake investigatory proceedings is
that excluded on purpose or did you not
think of that or is that Authority been
transferred to the doe uh thank you Mr
chairman that's an excellent question
and I will say that yes my intention in
uh as the original drafter of this bill
was to clarify that the investigative
role is now to be discharged by the
department of energy now again that may
or may not be the best answer that was
that's my suggestion at this
stage okay I have a follow-up question
as well and that's on the same page if
you go down to lines 25 and
26 it states that
uh essentially that settlement orders
shall be approved by the or settlement
agree agreements should shall be
approved by the um that have been
approved by the parties uh have to
be accepted by the commission
unless that the settlement provision is
contrary to law so if a settlement
provision didn't pass the just and
reasonable cost standard would that
justify rejecting the settlement
agreement as being uh contrary to
existing
law uh I think in honest answer to that
Mr chairman thank you that was another
really excellent question is it depends
if the record conclusively demonstrated
that the rates uh agreed to in a
settlement agreement did not meet the
just and reasonable standard then yes
that would make the settlement contrary
to law and under this language the
commission would have the authority to
reject
it okay thank you additional questions
for the consumer Advocate representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman thank you um
Advocate cre uh for taking my question I
um was looking through the bill and I
noticed I actually remember the 80 pages
that was added and I I was one of the
few people that actually read it and
having had some background in
organizational development I was
concerned at the time and I don't know
if you remember I actually mentioned to
you that I was concerned at the time
that in many places in the original
legislation that created the department
of
energy uh it stated both the commission
and the department right and I thought
at the time it was confusing to me that
they would share all these
responsibilities since one was an agency
and one was a regulatory body um I
thought it would create confusion so I
was pleased to see that you have things
struck in here to try and tighten up
where the responsibilities lie but it
seems like that might be um a large part
of what you're doing is sort of cleaning
up and then the other
piece seems like it's more about the
role of the Public Utilities Commission
in terms of uh getting the proceedings
to a
resolution uh in a timely manner which
again saves people money because they
can do more throughput if they if they
handle more cases so are both of those
things objectives of this bill um and if
if you could say a little bit more about
uh the roles and how how you uh see the
problem that we're currently facing uh
thank you for more excellent questions
representative McGee so with respect to
the two issues that you just raised you
have perfectly captured the first thing
that I'm trying to get at here which is
it was explicitly
understood uh in
2021 that there were ambiguities in
those 80 pages in the Budget Trailer
bill that you just referred to because
people wanted the legislature at the
time wanted and I I guess you didn't
agree with it at the time but that view
didn't Prevail the The View that
prevailed was we're going to leave that
kind of vague and Loosey Goosey and
we're going to sort out what would work
best you know who would do the
investigating and who wouldn't and there
were all sorts of authorities that
were uh designated or or allocated to
the department but not divested of the
Pu and I I think everybody knew at the
time that that was going to need to be
addressed I think four years later it is
time to address that question so so
you've understood me perfectly as to the
first point the second point is I I I
really do feel like we need clarity
about what the Pu is supposed to do and
not supposed to do because having the Pu
uh sort of flop around and conduct
freewheeling investigative proceedings
all the time costs a lot of money I walk
into the Pu hearing room my meter
doesn't really stop start I mean I you
know there is there's an opportunity
cost when I spend time in the Pu hearing
room but I don't start a meter but I
look in that room and there were 40
people in there all of whom you know
start up a a Time meter and charge time
to this regulatory process and the rate
payers get the bill and I I really think
that that is not an economically
efficient way to do utility regulation
and I know that doing this efficiently
and saving rate payers money is an
objective that every single member of
this committee has so that's what I'm
trying to do and I'm not telling you
that I have captured it perfectly here
I'm just trying to have the conversation
with you all you all are the
representatives of the people you have a
better sense of how to do this than I
than I
do yes followup so my followup would be
about um the settlement process which is
another piece that the bill Bill alludes
to my understanding of the settlement
process is that all of the parties have
to come together and present evidence to
the Public Utilities Commission for why
they have reached the conclusion that
they have so they provide the evidence
um and I in in my understanding of it
you know you would have to have a really
good reason to either question the
evidence or want to go find further
Evidence or other evidence because
that's that's how the proceedings
normally have gone right is that the
parties conclude come together and
present you with the easiest solution so
is that can you for the folks here who
haven't had a lot of experience with the
Public Utilities Commission and I know
that you
have is that the way it's been in the b
in the past and it's different now or I
mean I guess just paint for us a little
bit of a picture of what the settlement
process is intended to be and how you
think it's deviating from that indeed
I'm having Deja Vu because we had this
exact same conversation at the jel car a
few weeks ago about the pu's procedural
rules and uh representative Lynn who of
course is a very learned attorney uh and
former judge had the same question that
you just asked so there the Pu will tell
you I'm pretty sure that when they
review a settlement agreement they're a
lot like a court in a child protective
case they have this like kind of
independent responsibility not just to
uh bless what Mom and Dad have agreed to
but consider the best interest of the
child that's the analogy they draw the
problem with that analogy is that in
these pu proceedings you do have parties
that are interested in the broad best
interest kind of determination right you
have my office representing residential
rate payers and you have the department
of energy representing the I guess
policy imperatives that reflect the
governor essentially and so when you
have those two voices agreeing to
something alongside whatever utility or
utilities are involved and whatever
third parties have chosen to be involved
then then you really do have a really
broad consensus that's been developed
after a lot of work and thought and
evidentiary development uh that I think
is deserving of some degree of
difference when it comes before the puc
rather than just leaving the Pu free to
go eh you know we don't like that we
have a whole different approach in mind
and we're seeing that that the trend has
been more and more in that direction of
just saying I don't care what all all of
the stakeholders who have been meeting
for months and exchanging evidence for
months have all agreed to we you all
agree to why we prefer X I I I just I
think that's bad bad public policy so
the bill I drafted says you can't really
do that could you water that down or
modify that a bit and create maybe a
rebuttable presumption in favor of
settlements or something yeah you could
if you think my Approach is too extreme
but I think it's a it's again it's an
important conversation for you all to
have
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for being here uh
I almost called you Dr Chas um Mr Chas
um so can you tell me what would be
eliminated with this bill is it time
confusion money um and is there a direct
benefit to rate payers if this bill
would be passed it would eliminate all
of well it would reduce all of those
things I mean there there regulation
costs money there's no doubt about that
so and it's always important to think
about like does the cost of regulating
utilities justify the benefit of
regulating the utilities but this bill
is aimed at making that process more
responsive and efficient to the
stakeholders who after all are going
before the Pu because they need
something from the Pu good decisions
that can either be acted on or relied
upon or appealed
from hope that was somewhat responsive
thank
you so I'm still struggling with the
language uh on lines 21- 26 on page two
I'm sorry 23 through 26 on page
two the language there says help help me
understand this please the language
there says in any contested case before
the commission
in which the department of energy and
the office of the consumer Advocate are
parties the Commission in a timely
manner shall approve by order any settl
settlement agreement to which all
parties are a
signatory by sign singling out the
department of energy in the Office of
Consumer
Advocate does that mean
that any settlement agreement which is
Reed uh reached between parties do not
include the department of energy or the
consumer Advocate are not subject to
this language correct again you know you
obviously can amend the bill uh to
change that but that was that's my
suggestion okay thank you appreciate you
help helping me understand that further
questions representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman
um is
it uh I mean would it be fair would
would it be fair to
characterize the um I guess what you're
describing the
evolution of the public utilities
commission's role or the public
utilities commission's
Behavior since
2021 as um sort of analogous to like an
activist you know we hear people rail
against activist judges who you know
bring their own uh agenda or their own
um biases to to a case as opposed to
deciding the case on its merits and
evidence presented is that do you see
that that the Public Utilities
Commission has become sort of like an
rather than a neutral judge to to be an
activist
judge uh that is not the way I would
characterize it I think what I've
observed is is a Public Utilities
Commission in an Earnest struggle to
figure out what the legislature expects
of
it okay thank
you further
questions okay seeing none I want to
thank you for delivering your testimony
on this Bill thank you Mr chairman
you're very
welcome next I would like to call the
Public Utilities Commission Alex Bell
Comm commer D arano and chairman Dan
goldner Mr chairman uh chairman goldner
may make some remarks after commissioner
Delano if that is acceptable but that'll
be at we'll get to that bridge when we
cross if it's all right
okay good afternoon chairman Vose and
honorable members of the committee um
I'm Alexander spidel senior advisor at
the commission and I have with me
commissioner Delano I won't take up much
time I will seed the floor to him very
quickly um it's been voiced some
feedback that sometimes we get a little
technical in our testimony so I will be
short into the point um the proposed
Bill uh would really gut the public
utilities commission's
capabilities what it would do is it
would remove all of the investigative
authorities that we've maintained since
1911 and our general supervisory power
over Public Utilities that we've had
since
1911 and that was the time let's get in
the time machine that's when I believe
President William Howard Taft was
President just for a sense of
perspective and so there's focus on the
settlement provision which is
interesting but if you read the Preamble
and you read all the language here it
basically tells the commission it cannot
investigate it truly would be the blind
scales of Justice in the sense that a
even a court in the state of New
Hampshire does not have that position
and furthermore as chairman goldner and
our uh colleagues Commissioners and
others have already described we are not
a court we are creation of the
legislature with the responsibility
delegated by the legislature for the
regulation of
monopolies under the New Hampshire and
US
constitutions so I would caution that
this bill is a step in the wrong
direction
there are companion bills that also
potentially uh downgrade the
responsibility of the Department of
energy to provide timely information to
the commission uh I think commissioner
delafon will touch on that so I will now
seed the floor to commissioner Delano
thank
you good afternoon Mr chairman and
distinguish uh members of the house
senate technology and energy committee
my name is Mark
Delano uh presently now just for over
four weeks uh I serve at the public as a
commissioner of the New Hampshire Public
Utilities Commission I'm here today to
testify in opposition to House Bill
535 a bill requested by the office of
the consumer Advocate relative to
defining the role of the Public
Utilities Commission one of the things
I'd like to point out immediately about
that is is that we have a sister agency
that must appear before the Public
Utilities Commission coming before you
with legislation
that would actually change the way the
organization that he must appear before
and present a case before has to
operate before I get into my substantive
testimony however I want to provide you
with some background about myself I hope
this information will help you receive
my testimony against 535 as both
informed and
persuasive though I'm new to the Public
Utilities Commission I've worked in or
been involved with global energy and
natural resources Industries for most of
my
career before my service on the
commission I served the people of New
Hampshire as an Assistant Attorney
General at the New Hampshire Department
of Justice in that role I represented
the state's interests and agencies as
trial Council in adjudicative
proceedings under RSA 541a and contested
cases before the state Superior Court in
contested civil litigation and before
the federal trial courts involving
contested energy environmental matters I
also served as the state's appet Council
in appeals cases heard by New Hampshire
Supreme Court the US court of appeals
for the fifth circuit and the US court
of appeals for the District of Columbia
circuit before State service I was an
attorney in private practice at shenin
Bass and green where I represented
business and energy clients including
renewable energy developers energy
Brokers Energy Efficiency Consultants
independent generators oil and gas
companies although I was not a
landman private Equity firms investing
in uh conventional renewable and clean
energy development and Technology IES
Regional and National Banks supplying
tax Equity financing to renewable energy
projects
and at least one customer-owned public
utility before she and Finny I held
various legal and Leadership positions
over a 16-year career with a New
Hampshire based private Equity Firm that
invested in conventional and renewable
energy and resource extraction projects
and Technologies before my tenure in
private Equity I held positions at
General telephone and electronics
Corporation better known as GTE which
was a public utility before its merger
with bell Atlantic to form Verizon
subsequent to the Verizon merger I
worked for one of its subsidiaries
genuity going back even further uh right
after graduating from Manchester's West
High School I worked my first energy
industry job as a wood fuel technician
uh at one of New Hampshire's now
shuttered biomass power plants it's fair
to say that I've been in and around
energy regulated utilities for over 30
years turning to my testimony in
opposition to House Bill 535 I'm
troubled by the bill for several reasons
but in the interest of time I'll Focus
only on my top three reasons why the
honorable members of this committee
should find it inexpedient to legislate
firstly for reasons left unarticulated
by the consumer
advocate it appears that without
reasonable cause he would like the
Public Utilities Commission an
independent institution that
successfully regulate and supervis the
state's Public Utilities since at least
1911 to no longer have a role in the
supervision of the state's Public
Utilities if you look at paragraph two
of the proposed legislation it's clear
there
that the authority that the consumer
Advocate suggest just should be stripped
from the Public Utility Commission goes
to the very core of what it
does such a change to the Comm to the
commission's
authority would result in a wide
departure from the legislatur clearly
expressed intent of establishing the
commission is found by the the New
Hampshire Supreme Court to provide
comprehensive oversight for establishing
and controlling Public Utilities in this
state secondly the bill attempts to unre
reasonably flipped the burden of proof
for settlement agreements brought before
the Public Utilities Commission in an
adjudicative in an adjudicative
proceeding from being on the parties to
demonstrate to the commission that the
proposed settlement agreement is
consistent with applicable law is just
and reasonable and serves the public
interest instead the consumer Advocate
wants to put that burden on to the
Public Utilities Commission to find that
any settlement provision is contrary to
law put another way as presently drafted
subparagraph 5 lines uh 23- 26 of
paragraph 2 creates a presumption that
any settlement agreement signed by in
particular the the department of energy
and the consumer Advocate uh is
consistent with applicable law is just
and reasonable and serves the public
interest and therefore must be approved
by the Public Utilities Commission
unless the commission determines after a
hearing that any settlement provision is
contrary to law the flaw in that
statutory construction however is that
since all of the the commission's trial
staff were transferred to the Department
of energy three years ago no one is left
to present evidence on the record to the
commission that any settlement provision
of a proposed settlement agreement
signed by the department of energy the
consumer Advocate Andor all the
interveners is contrary to
law this problem is only magnified by
the apparent plan to strip the Public
Utilities Commission of any authority to
develop a record by which the commission
can determine whether a settlement
agreement is contrary to Law Without
Reliance on the investigative resources
of the Department of energy which I'll
remind you is a party to the settlement
agreement in those
cases public utility commission's
organization is actually based on the
Federal Energy Regulatory commission's
organization uh which presently under
current federal law is not required to
accept a proposed settlement agreement
just because the parties of the case
have agreed to it instead like the
authority of the Public Utilities
Commission presently the FK must still
find based on the party's proferred
evidence that a settlement agreement is
just reasonable and in the public
interest lastly and this goes more to
the core of uh just an observation that
I have as someone that has advised state
agencies when I was at doj I had advised
and represented 13 separate State
agencies a state agency should not
actively work to diminish the authority
of its sister
agencies even more outrageous than a
dispute between state agencies are
circumstances where is here a state
agency that must appear before a sister
agency to exercise its own statutory
purpose actually works to reduce that
agency's authority to accomplish goals
that may or may not be outside of its
statutory purpose I have the utmost and
I mean this utmost respect for the
consumer Advocate nevertheless any
efforts to diminish the public UT
Utilities Commission are wrong-headed
and serve only to weaken the state's
regulatory oversight of its Public
Utilities thank you I'm available for
any
questions okay thank you you presented a
lot of information there so I had to um
uh do a lot of note taking slowed me
down a bit so Representatives johs son
has his hand up but since he introduced
this bill he can't actually ask a
question um but we have other
questioners here so we'll start with
representative
McGee thank you Mr chair and I realize
you called on me because my committee
members my fellow committee members keep
deferring to me and we all go off at
once okay so I have a question for each
of you I'll start with you Mr spidel um
how many people did you have in the
Public Utilities Commission before the
the reorganization of
2021 I wasn't at the Public Utilities
Commission for about roughly three and a
half year Gap from 2018 when chairman
honberg was the chairman until February
of 2022 that's when I came back so the
split happened after my departure my
understanding was at the Staffing level
from the time of chairman honberg
through the time of chairman Martin and
the split in 21 was stable at about 75
personnel and how many do you have now
just so we can have a 12 line personnel
and three Commissioners okay thank
you um and then okay followup oh yes
followup I said I had a question for
each of them so I was just going to
thank you um so Mr orano uh Del orano
Del orano I'm sorry okay there was a
former commissioner Oro right okay I'm
projecting um my question was I I I
heard you say that
um that you thought it wouldn't be a
good idea to require that the Public
Utilities Commission had to approve a
settlement um that was agreed to by all
of the
parties um unless it uh was contrary to
law but the law already includes the
language of Justin reasonable so you
wouldn't be prohibited from finding a
case not just in reasonable and using
that as an as an exemption so I'm just
trying to figure out why you put that
out there because it it doesn't seem
like the bill takes that away from you
it basically says if it's in the law
which just and reasonable is in the law
that language is in the current law then
you would have that you would have that
Latitude
right I think the issue is is that when
you have all of the parties to the to
the case coming forward with the
settlement agreement there's no one left
to present why there might be an issue
that's contrary to law since we no
longer have trial staff we can't determ
we can't develop a record around that
somebody would need to present that to
us and given the way that this bill is
written we would be left with accepting
whatever it was that uh the consumer
Advocate the department of energy and
the intervening parties would present so
even if it was contrary to law how are
we supposed to get that into the record
if we have no ability to investigate any
longer and we have no trial staff to
present a case that could potentially
show that it's contrary to law uh I
would obviously welcome one of my
Assistant Attorney General friends from
the Department of Justice to come over
and do that but uh presently uh that
isn't in our statutory
scheme I thought I thought that was a
followup follow all right I'll allow
this one more followup thank you it
gives everybody more time to formulate
their questions anyway um so the the
question that I had about what you just
said was that you don't have the time
you know you wouldn't have the
opportunity to develop that own
investigation but do you have staff to
do that even if you H you were if if it
was in your purview how would you
accomplish that because you just I just
heard that you don't have the staff so
so presently the the commission has the
ability to make record requests of the
utilities the department of energy and
the consumer Advocate my reading of this
bill would eliminate that Authority so
if there are issues that are confusing
to the commission or the commission
would like more clarity on they can make
what's called a record request to as I
mentioned the utility the consumer
Advocate Department of energy or any of
the interveners and that party would
then present that evidence through that
the response to that uh that record
request this bill would eliminate in my
opinion that that
ability okay additional questions
representative Kaplan has
one thank you Mr chair and thank you
gentlemen uh this might be a related
question but just help me to understand
your objection to having the
investigatory uh capabilities being
placed in the department of energy um
there is a there's a settle there's a
negotiating process parties go before
the department of energy they go before
the uh the consumer Advocate they reach
a settlement
they come to you and you want to
investigate you go back to the
Department of energy to do that
investigation isn't that isn't that
redundant somehow I mean to to a lay
person that might seem like a you know
an inefficiency in the process so can
you explain so so first off I have
absolutely no issue with the
investigatory Authority being vested in
the department of energy that is where
the legislature has placed it and I have
absolutely no issue with it but what the
current Authority allows is it allows
for the Public Utilities Commission to
continue to uh explore issues that may
be presented before the commission
through record requests and that would
disappear if this were taken
away did does that address your question
sir so it it's it's it's just follow
followup question so it's strictly a
matter of a record request that you that
you to there are a few other elements
around that but it's primarily the the
record requests that would uh not be
allowed anymore the other the other
point and and then I'm going to address
the second point that you brought up
around the uh the the consumer Advocate
the department of energy and the
interveners getting together to uh
negotiate a settlement then presenting
it to the the Public Utilities
Commission the the Public Utilities
Commission has unlike a court has
independent uh statutory duties around
deter determining whether or not rates
are just reasonable and in the public
interest so if the department of energy
and the consumer Advocate and the and
the associated interveners all kind of
agreed that that's the case and the
Public Utilities Commission is now just
left in the position of rubber stamping
that agreement among them then how do we
meet our statutory duties we can't meet
them under that situation so
how do we reconcile the fact that we
have an independent obligation to make
sure these rates are proper but without
the ability to do that because we're
completely dependent on whatever comes
forward and we have no ability in this
situation to have anyone come forward
with information that might be contrary
to
law I don't understand how this works
and allows us to continue to uh exercise
our statutory Authority
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question would you clarify for us how
the contents of this bill would or would
not uh fix the three major concerns that
the OCA brought forward in his testimony
that seem to be the the Crux of his um
testimony frankly I don't think it
addresses any of those concerns
I followup followup U obvious followup
is could you explain why sure so one of
the issues that that uh the consumer
Advocate brought up was cost cost of
these
proceedings the the I think the trouble
is is that you're still going to have 40
lawyers in the room you're still going
to have uh you're still going to have
the consumer Advocate there you're still
going to have the department of energy
there you're going to have the the
commission staff your excuse me not
commission staff but the Commissioners
there so it doesn't really change the
cost of proceedings what it may do is it
may encourage people to come forward
with a settlement agreement but that
settlement agreement may not ultimately
be what's in the best interests of both
the utility and the rate base because
there's a careful balancing act that the
Public Utilities Commission must perform
when it's making those determinations it
needs to determine and and find and
allow for the
the customers of the regulated public
utility to pay the lowest rate possible
while also facilitating a capital
structure that allows the utility to
operate there may be cases out there
folks other than I should probably talk
about them where that may or may not
have been the case and so what I would
what I would suggest is that while I
think that the consumer Advocate put
forward a good faith effort here to
identify issues that he sees as
problematic I don't think that that
deals with the overall issue of cost
these are costly proceedings and the
reason why they're costly proceedings is
because of the pricing power that the
public utility has add to that the
interests that many times uh appear and
intervene in these proceedings with
their own uh matters that they would
like to see baked into rates it opens up
the the proceedings to you know a a long
evidentiary period
representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for being here um you testified at
some length about the unarticulated
arguments by the uh or unarticulated
facts by the consumer Advocate I'm
wondering just how one does articulate
what is
unarticulated however my question is
have you met to have any discussions
directly about this bill with the
consumer advocate
he and I have discussed this this topic
previously and and we just don't see eye
to eye on it follow up follow up um and
you also presented your extensive legal
background can you tell me how many of
the other Commissioners have legal Andor
law
backgrounds I don't I can't answer that
ma'am thank
you okay seeing no further questions for
the two of you I understand that
chairman goldner would like to
make some closing remarks
or okay nothing further to add in that
case we'll call forward the last uh
party that wants to testify on this bill
and that is the combination of
commissioner Chris Elms and David
shulock from the Department of
energy good afternoon commissioner
welcome back and good afternoon Mr
shulock nice to see you again good
afternoon Mr chairman uh and members of
the committee again for the record uh
Deputy Commissioner Chris Elms of the
New Hampshire Department of energy
joined by Doe general counsel David
shulock uh for the time being we are
neutral on House Bill 535 uh we are here
to express some concerns with the bill
as
written uh so you know to give you
context on my background obviously some
of you knew me uh in my previous role uh
with the governor's office
uh where I served as legislative
director when this when this uh
legislation was moving forward in the
2021 budget um as we all might well for
those of us who were there we might
remember that this was a very big
undertaking and it was happening pretty
quickly and so as part of part of the uh
H having this able to move forward uh
the legislature in their wisdom built in
a number of safeguards and overlapping
jurisdictions to help ensure that
regardless of how things turned out we
were able to pick up the pieces wouldn't
have Things fall through the cracks and
we were able to support uh you know a a
successful regulatory process here in in
New Hampshire uh you know the department
of energy was created in part to
restructure uh the Pu with the intention
of separating out the rate making
functions and the um
adjudication uh from the you know some
of the other regulation the policy work
the regulatory advocacy and and the
programs that the department of energy
uh was was given also
enforcement and that was you know that
was a big task right and so the the uh
the overlapping jurisdictions that you
built into place were successful right
there was some bumpiness in the first
couple of months but but really all in
all we have been able to function and
and and frankly we've we've fallen into
a rhythm where I think we can you know
keep working things out
and uh you know that's not to say there
aren't occasional disagreements I think
among the state agencies as you'll as
you've seen and as as I'm sure you're
you're well aware of uh about what the
proper role of the commission is and
whether or not they are stretching the
bounds of what the legislature intended
for the commission back in 2021 and so I
do think that this bill is
well-intentioned in a purist kind of way
you know the the the concept of sort of
finishing the job uh to to remove the
sort of the Temptation from the from the
commission to go outside of their
legislatively intended Lane but I do
think that this bill as written is is
heavy-handed and I think it guarantees
that we're going to see more confusion
not less um and and that honestly
important issues have a pretty good
likelihood of falling through the
cracks um in it search for conceptual
Purity uh it's going to disadvantage
customers regulated utilities pretty
significantly um I think it does try to
answer what are you know genuinely you
know not not non-existent but smaller
problems with very consequential
Solutions so obviously this pu uh
Authority would would be reduced under
this bill uh you know it would limit
their authority to conduct adjudicative
proceedings and adopting rules they no
longer have their authority to conduct
inspections and investigations supervise
the public utilities keep itself
informed regarding Utilities in the
state or to receive reports of proposed
Capital Improvements
all of those duties would fall solely
with the Department uh in addition the
the commission would no longer have
authority to question the justness or
Reason reasonableness of settlements
that are entered into by the department
and the OCA and last the department
would have the duty to be uh and be
required to petition the commission for
appropriate relief uh whenever the
department reasonably believes that a
public utility is failing to meet uh or
discharge their obligations and uh all
of that's variously problematic but that
last bit is what I want to focus on on
uh creating a duty for the Department of
energy to petition the Pu for corrective
action will add significant cost and
inefficiency to some existing processes
where the doe currently acts informally
and independently from the commission uh
to correct action by the utilities so to
give you an example we are responsible
for the enforcement of the underground
damage prevention program more commonly
known as digsafe and uh obviously
utilities do a lot of the work that
falls under dig saafe
uh or their contractors do and
potentially they are responsible for
violations there and there there're a
significant Chunk in the 40% range I
think and I can get you in numbers on
that but it's a significant chunk and so
if we had to go uh to the Pu for every
utility related Dig Safe violation that
would add several dozen proceedings uh
that we can currently resolve uh with a
process that's laid out in rule but that
is uh efficient and folks know how to
work with it and we can you know Levy
the appropriate penalties without
creating the significant work associated
with a pu proceeding uh the several
dozen extra proceedings every year alone
would represent a significant uh
resource need for the Department uh to
to uh have us be able to do a a function
that we currently are able to do
effectively and
efficiently um so you know I think if
this bill were to move forward there
would be some significant needs from the
Department in order to make sure we were
not letting things fall through the
cracks you know if you want to finish
the job so to speak of clarifying the
responsibilities it's going to
significantly reduce the authority of
the
Pu and if you want to do that we should
take some time with it part of the
reason that the the restructuring of the
Pu and the creation of the department
was able to happen so quickly back in
2021 was because of the guard rails and
because of the overlapping jurisdictions
and and and safeguards that we put into
place so if you want to start removing
those safeguards and and and uh you know
uh
jurisdictional uh add jurisdictional
Clarity you can do that but we really
ought to spend time with it you ought to
bring in folks from uh you know your
colleagues uh at Edna legislative
leadership the governor's office the
Attorney General's office there would be
a lot that would go into that and
frankly uh you know I'm we're not sure
that the the problem that this bill is
solving is at this point you know ripe
for the bill we have in front of us so
obviously if you do intend to move
forward with something uh the department
would be happy to participate and happy
to uh you know help help the legislature
but as written we don't think this bill
is ready to go happy to take
questions unless David do you want to
add anything
okay
so this is a kind of a general concern
of the committee but it's also specific
to this
bill if you look on the last page page
of the reproduced copy of the
legislation there is a fiscal
note and the fiscal note says that the
department was contacted on 12 2624 for
a fiscal note
worksheet and that when completed it
will be forwarded to the house clerk's
office well I've seen no sign of this
fiscal note and I have a stack right
here of
fiscal notes for bills that have been
assigned to this committee that all say
the same
thing where is it you know where are
these fiscal notes and in particular
we'd like to understand the financial
implications of this bill so do you have
any any information that you could
Supply to us until we receive a fiscal
note on this
bill so we received about 30
request for fiscal note worksheets
during that time period it just takes a
while to get through all of them but
we've just about done that uh we did
send uh a a fiscal note worksheet to the
LBA for this bill just recently um and
um our biggest concern is is the the
duty uh imposed on us to take everything
to the Pu that would require us we think
to add at least three new employees
uh to our staff at a cost of over
$400,000 per year I think in the first
year we're looking at
$49,000 and by 2028 uh
$427,000 a year and that in my
estimation is actually a low ball in
terms of the staff that we would need if
we had to take everything to the Pu for
adjudication excellent that's the kind
of information we need for bills like
this representative McGee yeah I I don't
know where are you referring to in this
bill that it says that the department of
energy would have to take everything to
the Pu for adjudication because I didn't
see that as being part of the
bill uh so that would be on page two
lines 5 through
n oh I'm sorry page
three lines two through
five this imposes imposes upon us a duty
to petition the commission for
appropriate relief either through and
and there are statutes listed those are
fining authorities or authorities to uh
convince the Pu that a matter that we
think is important enough uh should be
taken to the Attorney General's office
which we do on our own anyhow right but
now we would have to go to the Pu and
ask them to do it right um so there are
a number of things uh you know where
where we can see a public utility faing
to discharge its obligations and um you
know I don't want you to leave with the
impression that public utilities are
awful and they do everything wrong um
but you know just given the size of our
state the number of customers it it
happens right um and uh what we normally
do is we work with the utility to
resolve the matter and we do it
relatively inform in informally
utilities are responsive uh for the most
part um and we're able to resolve that
but here if we find that they're
violating a rule right and they violated
a rule and failed to discharge their
obligations we have to go to the Pu and
ask for them to be fined that's what the
that's the meaning of this this
statement and yeah that's that's he
wasn't finished explaining okay no I
that's that's basically it yeah okay
follow up please thank you um so that
sounds like that might be a place where
from the sounds of it everyone could
agree that maybe that is a bridge too
far and is maybe not going to increase
efficiency right if it's going to uh
remove something from the doe that you
currently can do in an informal way and
it doesn't have to be gummed up with
more
regulatory but my question would be it's
sounds as though I mean we we heard
testimony that we've gone to a dozen
people from about 70s something with
this you know reorg it sounds as though
the Pu may be understaffed in terms of
people that you guys took under your
wing At Doe I mean attorney shock you're
one of them um so I'm just curious is is
there any conversation about adequate
Staffing for the Pu to be able to
conduct the kind of proceedings they're
looking to do so that maybe they
wouldn't have to um pull up at a
settlement or at at a point where people
are ready to move forward and and get it
get it off the books and go on to the
next thing um because it seems to be
that that might have been the impetus
for us to be taking a look at how well
it's working sure and it's a good
question thank thank you very much
representative um and and and I don't
want to speak obviously for the
Commission in their own uh you know
staffing needs because that's something
that they should be able to articulate
and obviously we're in a budget process
and the agency you know as the governor
is putting their their things together
they had an opportunity in this budget
and previous budgets to bring forward
some of those considerations uh you know
we certainly have and and every state
agency does look at that um you know
going back to in my background to when
this was put into effect I think that
does show some of the legislative intent
of what was was was envisioned for the
Pu uh when that was being created and
obviously the chairman of the Pu at the
time as we know was was you know
involved in those conversations to um
you know uh look at look at uh what this
new iteration what this new department
and commission are going to look like
and that was where folks landed and
there obviously were some changing of
personnel we had a lot of people come to
the doe who were existing employees that
we also added six highlevel unclassified
positions as senior advisers over at the
Pu
to help give them an opportunity to have
experienced attorneys and analysts who
can participate uh in the process um and
when you look at sort of the size of the
agency um you know we have what you know
uh somewhere it's in the in the 80s uh
now and obviously with uh full-time
temporary positions part-time employees
it's it's close to 90 uh employees at
the department of energy well that
includes a lot of folks who are
implementing programs who are our
consumer services folks who are working
in our business office who are uh going
out and doing pipeline safety
inspections and things like that so when
you talk about what the
regulatory uh you know Frontline uh
workers are I I I think uh as as Mr
spidel or attorney spidel alluded to you
know we don't have a a
significantly uh more large group you
know we have uh less than 20 folks uh in
our util utility analysts in our
regulatory Support Division we have a
handful of attorneys so obviously there
are uh there's a lot of work to go
around I think part of the uh the
Staffing that was envisioned at the time
was that the Pu is going to have a
reduced role from what they had uh prior
to the split in 2021 um so you know uh I
hope that answers your question David I
don't know if you want to add
anything I thought you just had one no
yeah I think you
did so we've been told by the finance
committee the house finance committee
that we should not bring them any
bills that require the expenditure of
funds without an
appropriation and this be Bill appears
to fall into that
category as someone who has to deal with
uh their agency budget do you see that
as a significant problem to this bill
going forward
that's a good question it obviously
doesn't have a general fund
appropriation but the employees that
we'd be envisioning there are are a
combination of uh assessment funds in
which case that that would have to be
accounted for in the utility assessment
uh specifically with the Dig Safe
program which is where I had a lot of
concerns in terms of having to staff up
those are federal funds and obviously uh
even even prior to the change in
administration uh I I would have to go
back and see if we were going to be able
to to uh get the necessary federal funds
to match whatever we would need to do to
ramp up our underground damage
prevention staff and obviously um
there's there a lot of questions now
related to where Federal funding is
going to go um and so I could not tell
you that we would have the funding
available on the federal side to to do
what we needed to do okay representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair I'm sorry oh so um so this is in
regards to what you pointed out on page
three the highlighted section um and
your concern is that you would have to
go if this passed you would have to go
directly to the puc for any cases or
matters um that would come to the doe
can you give me an idea of how many
cases or matters we're talking about on
a yearly basis I think it's ranged from
40 to 70 in recent years uh just on the
Dig Safe program alone
for utility related Dig Safe violations
followup followup and and so you
testified that we need three or four
additional staff members to handle 40 to
70 matters a year is that correct yeah
uh yeah so in that case we would likely
need to ramp up our our actual
inspection staff the folks going out to
do the Dig Safe inspections because
those folks would need to be able to um
you know you know ramp up their own
individual time where they would be
spending having to go and take about 40%
of their violations through this
adjudicated process uh our attorney
workload is already pretty strained so
that would probably necessitate another
attorney um what am I I just want to say
it's not just Dig Safe that's just an
example so um you know
what uh we prosecute approximately 140
Dig Safe violations a year
about half of those are directly with
utilities um plus we have pipeline
safety violations which are different
from Dig Safe that's enforcement of a
federal pipeline
program um and then we have thousands
and thousands and thousands of consumer
contacts uh with consumers complaining
that a utility has violated a rule uh
they've mischarged on their bill uh
they're not charging fairly all of which
would be failure to perform obligations
under the title and would have to be
brought to the Public Utilities
Commission rather than informally
resolved as we currently
do and just to add to that obviously
staff we going to be going to the Pu to
be sworn in to testify in that setting
uh that is a skill set that Demands a
higher you know level of of uh
experience and that
expertise okay additional questions
representative McGee has another thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question so I think when the consumer
Advocate uh spoke on this bill he
mentioned that it was sort of a it was a
starting point to get the conversation
going to let us become more aware of
what the problems might be if the bolded
language uh on page three between lines
two and and five was removed then would
that also negate the need for the note
because that's the only part of the bill
where it appears that would be Personnel
involved
correct we'd have to go back and focus
on the other duties so one of the things
that would happen when you took
supervisory Authority away from the
commission and allowed them only to
adjudicate contested cases right uh
would be
that we would be supervising the
attorneys as the or I'm sorry the um the
utilities at the department
and agencies supervis by rule now uh
when the reorganization first took place
uh we were confronted with the task of
taking the public utility commission's
uh rules and dividing those sets into
rules for each of the agencies we're
only about three4 of the way through
that three and a half years in right in
addition to that we would have to create
rule sets for things that are currently
handled in uh commission investigations
and other types of dockets including
adjudications where things are handled
by settlement um and probably could no
longer be handled that way so it would
there would be quite a bit of work right
which uh in the original reorganization
was planned to happen afterwards here we
have the opportunity to give it some
forethought and uh that that would be
our recommendation
follow up The Logical followup would
just be how you said you're three
quarters the way through so when do you
anticipate that you would have that
information uh we expect to be through
separating the the rule
sets um I think in the fall of 2026 is
the current
timeline representative CL has a
question uh thank you chair and thank
you commissioner
um I have a question after I mentioned
three notes I'm going to paraphrase from
early testimony with the consumer
advocate in the Pu uh I got a note here
that um the department of energy and the
puc needed guidance
um excuse me um and then yourself
mentioned that there's overlapping from
the previous legislation between the doe
and the pu which still allowed you to
function even with the internal issues
the question now is does the dle benefit
from the
legisl asking to look into this again to
see if you need more
guidance that's a good question it's a
very good question thank you
representative you know I I think from
our perspective we view our role as the
executive branch agency to to respond to
what the legislature wants right so if
you are hearing from folks if you feel
like things need to be clarified then
that's something we would we would be
prepared to help you do we don't see it
as our role as the department of energy
as the administrative state to tell you
what things should be like we see it as
your role to tell us what the problem is
and we help you fix it so that's that's
kind of how I view it I hope that's
answers your question if you want to do
something we're here to help you but we
don't we don't want to tell you this is
what must happen because we know better
than
you follow uh thank you and to the chair
yes um I anticipated your answer I just
wanted to get on record that I saw some
a need of something thank you thank
you representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
gentlemen um
yeah I'm I'm trying to wrap my head
around this uh and so from your
testimony it sounds like you know it
cuts both ways like this this bill could
bring up as many problems as it causes
and uh the the system that is in play in
place now has sort of built in
redundancies which also cut both ways
that could be good or bad um and you
mentioned that you are working it out
that that you know that that it's
evolving and it's getting better um but
we have some serious concerns that have
been raised here and so I want some more
clarification if I could from you uh as
to could you give us an example using
the the net metering docket for for you
know for instance could you give us an
example of how that will be improved
upon so that we don't have these the
same issues arising in the future I
apologize I don't what was the issue
with the net metering docket I mean it
was raised in previous testimony here
that that was an example that where the
parties had come to an agreement uh had
come before the Pu and then the Pu you
know sort of scuttled it and said you
know we're going to well I appreciate
that representative in the net metering
docket my understanding was that there
were essentially three proposals one
that was a a settlement by many of the
parties one from Community power
Coalition of New Hampshire and then
another from the Department of energy uh
and the department of energy differed on
the issue of a legacy period related to
net metering from the settlement
agreement and the Pu more or less
adopted the department of Energy's
position so we didn't have an issue
there with the
uh with that the result of that
one okay seeing no further questions we
want to thank you both for being here
and since I have no more pink cards I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 5
35-
FN and very shortly we will begin a
public hearing on
hp450 relative to commercial property
assess clean energy and
resiliency otherwise known as C
spacer in order to or C Pacer sorry so
in order to um get that public hearing
rolling we need to have a short break
here because I have been asked to
introduce this bill by the Speaker of
the House who is its prime
sponsor so please bear with me while
I get my stuff get together here and
turn over the gavel to Vice chair
Thomas
e
e e
okay we are ready to uh proceed with HB
450 I open the public hearing for hp450
relative to commercial property assessed
clean energy and resiliency otherwise
known as C Pacer we have the uh in in
place of speaker packet we have
representative uh chairman Michael Vose
to intr introduce the bill the floor is
yours representative thank you Vice
chair Thomas and good afternoon again to
the members of the
committee for the record representative
Michael Bose representing the
speaker speaker Sherman Packard and
Rockingham District 5 I'm here to
introduce house bill for 50 relative to
commercial property assess clean energy
and
resiliency otherwise known as C
Pacer you will note if you look at the
first page of the bill the sponsor list
includes uh representative
Simpson and uh that makes this a
bipartisan submission representative s
Simpson of course is the minority leader
in the house
this is the third time that or at least
the third time since I've been involved
with the legislature that this
legislation has come before the house
we've passed two previous versions of
this
program which is a program that's
modeled after legislation that was
developed elsewhere in the
country to enable the creation
of clean in industry districts within
municipalities to assist with the
process of getting buildings
upgraded commercial property upgraded
for Energy
Efficiency the two previous attempts to
pass this
legislation while the passage of the
legislation was successful the
legislation itself did not work in
practice the way it was expected to when
it when it passed the
legislature so this is a new attempt to
get the C Pacer legislation to
work and we've got a couple of folks
here who are much more knowledgeable
about this program than I am much more
up todate on the latest Provisions
within this legislation that will
hopefully make it work so so I'm going
to defer to them to explain to you
exactly how the changes to this
legislation will make it finally work
and do the job that we want it to do
here in New Hampshire which is to enable
commercial buildings to be upgraded for
Energy Efficiency in a way that is
Affordable to those building
owners I'll be happy to take questions
if you want but I'm probably going to
defer most of them to to other
folks thank you representative are there
any questions for the representative
that he can defer to the people behind
them
yeah okay seeing no questions for the R
thank you representative o and I will I
will announce the next speaker will be
Mr James kallis from the New Hampshire
business Finance Authority
there we go good afternoon uh for the
record I'm James key Wallace I'm the
executive director of the state's
business Finance Authority uh thank you
for having me today and uh thank you Mr
chairman for introducing the bill uh so
what I'd like to do is just say a few
things about cace and why this latest
iteration of cace came to the BFA um and
then maybe just walk through what's in
their proposal and I'm happy to of
course answer any questions um so the
the BFA has not been involved in any of
the previous attempts for cace um
they've all been very honorable and and
I think semis successful attempts um and
yet haven't really resulted in any
actual lending in the state so so we
were approached by both folks who make
cace loans which by the way are all
private Capital lenders and project
owners which by the way are also all
private project owners so this is
private capital for private projects
this is a voluntary program this does
not impose any obligations on anyone to
meet any particular standards the
municipalities opt in if they want to so
this is fully voluntary it doesn't cost
the state or towns or anyone anything um
so they approached us and said BFA you
know lending and you know how to
administer programs so can you take a
look at the existing state statute make
some recommendations and turn it into a
potential Bill and that's what we did so
the process that we went through was to
evaluate the 20 plus 25 other active
cpce programs around the country we
didn't get get them all we just went and
looked at what we thought were the good
ones um it demonstrated by a high volume
of lending said well what are you doing
that we're not doing some of them are
doing a good job some we think New
Hampshire could do a little better I
won't name names but um so we took some
best practices and we went to the
different stakeholder groups such as the
municipal Association the bankers
Association project developers just the
folks affected by the bill right and
said how does this not work for you
where are the sticking points developed
this amend this proposed statutory
change so what we found were a few kind
of key
things the existing statute had a number
of seemingly minor but actually major
technical problems and I'll give you
just for you know one example of the
many and I can give you as many as You'
like the exist existing cpce statute
says any cace lender needs to file a
mortgage on the property which they're
financing and I can give you a quick
cpce primer in a moment actually if that
would be helpful but one of the things
that's unique about cace is it's in fact
not a mortgage and so you had the
statutory requirement right in plain
language that immediately kind of
prevented any cpce loan from going
forward so you take that and you put
that several times different things
throughout the legislation and you've
got the inability to actually make
loans the second big thing was cace is a
program where the municipalities are
involved in some of the billing and
administration of the program but it
didn't provide municipalities with any
support any guidance every municipality
had to run their own program which would
be expensive hard to do and especially
some of our smaller communities said
well this is burdensome we just
literally don't know how to do this and
we can't do it so it introduces the BFA
this which what other states do as a
central administrator which really is
like a clerk of the works right you know
form documents answer questions guide
people through the process just help run
checklists honestly um nothing
particularly complex but um it's what
you need to run a program so technical
changes Central administrator role
um those are the two things I'm happy to
answer questions and I'm happy to kind
of do a cpce 101 if that would be
helpful for the committee thank
you okay uh before we turn to questions
I want to point out something that I
probably should have said when I was
introducing the bill that's relevant to
this
process the Senate has already passed
this bill
their version of The Bill had one line
in it that this bill does not
have and according to the speaker's
office that is the preferred version of
the
bill the Senate the full Senate is going
to pass that bill either this Thursday
or next Thursday I'm not entirely sure
exactly when they're meeting but they're
going to pass it within the next two
weeks and the speak speaker's office is
going to Fast
Track that version of the bill through
the house which means he's going to
assign it to this committee so we're
going to get this bill from the Senate
and it'll be virtually identical to the
one we're looking at right here except
there will be one additional line added
to it and at that time it is hoped by
the speaker's office that we will pass
the Senate version of the
bill and if we do that then the bill can
be enrolled and sent to the governor so
that it can um take
effect in the very near future so
that the program can be
administered
Statewide so uh given that uh
reality I wanted you to understand that
reality as you tried to form your
questions um for the gentleman who will
be speaking here this morning or this
afternoon representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um Mr chair and I I realize
you introduced the bill so there might
be some conflict with you answering
questions but um can you let us know
what that one line is and what it
says when I find out what it is I will
be happy to let you know thank you I I
don't know off the top of my head maybe
Mr Sam Evans Brown knows I I I know Mr
chairman if be helpful well here we go
yeah thank you very much so there are uh
two what I would consider um two
changes um let me pull it out so I can
actually give you the exact reference
one I would call a
typo um and one I would call a
clarification
so on the top of page
five at the
end of sentence one and the beginning of
sentence two you'll see the word owners
with no apostrophe crossed out and the
word owners with an apostrophe added so
that that is incorrect um and it
actually matters because it's speaking
to what the Senate bill says is it's on
line one enter into agreements with
owners of eligible property the of which
the owners have consented right because
there's often multiple so I consider
that it's a typo
right uh actually no apostrophe
it's and so the language in the Senate
says in which the owners have consented
right so that's like a okay right so the
more um I think interesting one and is
uh on Page Six line uh starting on line
24 and this is what I would call a
clarification so this this clarifies
okay so let me back up so the the way
this program runs is businesses or
Housing Development apply for cace right
and part of what gets supplied as an
application for a loan are confidential
business financial statements personal
financial statements all type of
sensitive information
that if you look at the bfa's existing
exemptions under 91a are exempt from
disclosure because no one's going to
apply if they think you know your
business's financial statements are now
available to your competitors so the
house version on that paragraph
beginning on N uh line 24 page
six labels that information as
confidential information the Senate
version does the same but also
specifically references the exemption
clause in 91a for the removal of any
doubt as to the confidentiality of that
information so those are the two things
um other than that the the two bills are
identical okay great uh does anybody
have any questions representative rolds
I do thank you Mr chairman um thanks for
being here today uh Could you um you
know this might be uh an entree
or an opening for you to for you to give
that that P cpce 101 if if you want but
I just was just wondering if you could
offer for you know everyone on the
committee's uh illumination the
rationale for this whole concept of a
special
assessment for
financing Energy Efficiency improvements
to buildings why why is this thing
necessary and why have we been trying
for several years to get it enacted here
in New
Hampshire happy to representative right
where where's the beef right like what's
this all about yeah right so uh so cace
is commercial property assessed clean
energy although it's a little broader
than that but um what cace is is it's a
lending program where a private lender a
bank or CPA specialized lender um
they're all over the country can say
Okay representative you are you know
fixing the drafty windows in your
building because it's going to save you
money and blah blah blah blah blah
right correct yeah so
commercial could be an apartment
building so it's any kind of commercial
industrial or multif family residential
five units or more is considered uh
commercial under New Hampshire law right
so um so you want to do that so one
option is
you get the loan right we make you the
loan pretend I'm the bank I make you the
loan you write your monthly check like
you pay any loan that can be fine there
are certain times where the payback
period of the energy investment maybe
it's an 11-year payback it makes sense
to do um but the time in which the loan
needs to get repaid is longer than what
a normal loan they might say well let's
look at your collateral let's look at
this I can only offer you a loan that
you pay back over 5 years but it kind of
takes 11 years to you know but stretch
that loan out so the payments match the
savings that's pretty common in you know
efficiency uh investments in a building
right they're they're long-term a lot of
the time so what cace allows A lender to
do is instead of getting paid back via
their monthly check you write you are
actually paid back as the lender via
your payments you make on your property
tax bill for the property so it's not in
lie of your other property taxes the
town still gets paid all everything they
get they get paid but you get a new line
item on your tax bill that's equal to
the payments and that does some actually
some pretty interesting things if you're
a lender you know one is it increases
the security position of that loan
because if the building is sold or you
go out of business or you foreclose or
whatever some things go wrong whoever
comes into that building and buys it
after
you gets that same line item so as long
as someone's in the building and they're
paying their taxes that lender cpce loan
is eventually going to get paid I mean
they're only going to they they sign up
for that when they buy it right so it's
full consent and awareness it's this is
an informed kind of private Market
transaction but it helps the cpce folks
know I'll get paid one day and that lets
them take have more patience in how long
they get paid so they can match up the
savings of the project to the monthly
payments and there's sort of this Niche
window of projects that will apply to
people are excited about this developers
are excited
lenders I'm a little more measured in
what I think it will do I think this is
just one tool in the toolbox I think
it's helpful
we'll definitely see projects it's not a
light the world on fire Silver Bullet um
but it's helpful when it's it's
helpful yes thank you Mr chairman um in
the world of you know building uh
Renovations and um Energy Efficiency
upgrades you know
windows and uh things like furnaces are
um high efficiency furnaces are
good examples of things where the
efficiency upgrade has a long payback
and uh owners which is to say landlords
owners of buildings who have all their
paying tenants are often reluctant to
make those Investments right so is this
tool also intended
to um facilitate or you know take reduce
the risk uh for for owners of buildings
to or just say incentivize them to make
those kinds of efficiency upgrades that
they might not otherwise make because
they have such a long payback and if
they sell the building they're not going
to get that return necessarily but now
the loan that the loan goes with the
building as opposed to being with the
owner yes representative I don't think I
could have said it better that's exactly
what happens uh people say boy I'd love
to do this but I don't know if I'll own
this building for 15 years right now
they can do it the savings are generated
everyone benefits and they don't have to
own the building for 15 years and the
project can still go forward and their
tenants though continue to benefit from
absolutely that's exactly right yes
thank you reper Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question just a curiosity question uh
does this program would commercial
owners be eligible for this program even
if they took a advantage of other
efficiency programs like New Hampshire
saves or things like that uh thank you
Mr Vice chair great question the answer
is yes um this is a private lending
program that if you as a private
property owner can convince A lender
you're a good credit risk and the nature
of the Improvement fits within the
definition of c Pacer um which is uh you
know energy focused but flexible um then
sure yeah it doesn't have any kind of
you know you can only do this on
Thursdays but not Fridays and that kind
of stuff you
know representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um and this is a question
on what you have just explained um you
talked about the line item on the
property taxes is there a percentage cap
for that
um or can it be I mean how how do we how
is that established and what is is the
the maximum amount that one is allowed
to
borrow great question so that would be
set really by two simultaneous parties
right one would be whoever is deciding
to lend the money to the project they
have to decide this project can support
it right and they look at the cash flow
and they make a decision on is this a
creditworthy situation the other equally
important party is any exist in mortgage
holder so you know most properties you
finance to build to begin with and one
of the important elements of this bill
is that it requires the consent of any
existing say Bank who has a mortgage
holder that way they've made a loan and
already just to like build the place
right and they don't want it turned
upside down so they they have the
ability to consent to the additional
indebtedness excellent thank
you okay representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you so much for explaining this I I read
this a few days ago and it just has
completely gone out of my head so um how
is the municipality involved other than
being the one that is um doing the
property tax and presumably taking the
money and then bringing it over to the
lender uh what does the municipality
have to
do so under current law they have to do
that as well as develop all the the loan
documents vet the
contractors administer the program vet
the lenders it's just it kind of
something you need a fairly large
apparatus to do Under the new proposal
um they are responsible if they so
choose for the billing that you
mentioned right they just on their
property tax bill um they do have to
record the mortgage and the like there's
a there's not a mortgage like the
assessment gets recorded it's a recorded
instrument of record um but the
municipality has the option if they want
to do it thems because it doesn't take
anything away from them um but they have
the option to delegate that to a third
party which is how almost every town
that does cpce anywhere in the country
does it and the most common example of
how that works is actually the same
thing when you pay your personal
mortgage right you have your property
taxes that are owed to the town you
don't usually cut two checks one to your
lender one to the town you you pay your
bank there's an escrow and then that
escrow account is periodically released
um to the towns and you know to your
insurance company and stuff like that so
that's typically actually how this is
done follow up and do I I think I recall
reading something about districts so are
there districts carved out for this how
does that work yeah great great question
so in order for a project to be eligible
for C paace because this is a it's
technically a municipal lean even though
it's a special kind of lean um the town
has to create a district in which those
leans can be placed so the town or city
needs to opt in to the program and draw
a circle in their borders and say this
is where cace can happen most
municipalities and states that run these
programs adopted as a blanket corner to
corner rule um there's not a particular
[Music]
reason why you'd say only over here and
not over over there um because there's
not a lot of downside to them adopting
it yes sir Vice chair Thomas has another
question thank you Mr chair I'll use up
my follow on question to just again a
curiosity so the town adopts the program
is this by way of just their selectman
or Town Council voting on it or is this
something that has to be brought before
the town people in the form of a
warrant that's a great question I I
think it actually depends on the town's
setup right I think some towns have
Alderman or cities and you know C
they're empowered to do certain votes
some have to go to town meeting you know
some are I forget the term I I think the
municipal associations here is probably
saying you know this is an easy question
but I actually don't know it um you know
some of like Selectmen and hybrid so I
think it whatever the town has to do to
create taxing districts according to
what the town is set up they have to do
and that's probably not a great answer
representative schneller has a
question thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for taking my question yes sir uh my
original question was going to be why is
there such legislative Firepower
attached to this particular piece of
legislation just looking at this and um
then after you've explained it it's it's
very clear there's very Innovative um so
my next question only marginally Germain
is what if the property is
refinanced how does that flow
through uh the tax bill really
ultimately great great question um I I
think I think there might be you know a
one and a onea there so I think the
Firepower is because of the recognition
that there are a lot of potential new
housing developments that can be
unlocked with this in addition to
Commercial and that's one of the topics
of the day um and for good reason the
refinance question it it depends on
which debt is being refinanced so you're
going to have assumedly a bank loan
conventional bank loan secured by a
mortgage and then you have this cpce
loan
underneath with the tax assessment
structure if it's the bank loan that's
being refin financed nothing changes for
the cpce loan right it's just it keeps
on ticking the way that it is if it's a
new cace loan then how it works is the
old cace loan is if it's refinanced is
paid the recorded instrument is released
you get a loan payoff statement just
like you do with any other loan and then
a new one is added and so one comes off
one comes on it it's really not that
different than a normal Loan in that
regard yeah thank you yes
sir representative partiall has a
question thank you chair now please tell
me if I understand this correctly um the
uh property tax uh financing is on top
of whatever additional property tax it
will not affect the property tax revenue
of any given municipality however at the
end when the the conclusion of the
program any improvements are
taxable yes great question so what's one
of the reasons that you see eventually
usually see markets warm up to cace
after kind of there was some trepidation
and what the markets have determined
over time is these improvements improve
values right so debts are finally
reduced but now you have a better
property you know and if an owner um I
mean I guess no one likes to pay more
taxes maybe they do I don't know but you
know if the value is up and the town
assesses you higher as a result all
things being equal you'll be paying more
property taxes um that's what happens I
guess when you improve your property uh
so I'm told price of civilization I
guess may ask you followup go yes uh not
actually a followup um could I ask you
if the name of the honorable Mana puty
is familiar was she was she on the
original drafting of this already in law
she was is on the version she may have
been on both versions that I've seen
come through this house actually now
that I think of it yes thank you it was
again okay any additional
questions all right seeing none
fantastic job and it's great to see you
again here in the house thank you Mr
chairman it's a pleasure
now I asked uh Sam Evans Brown if he
would be willing to uh talk about this
bill because as a former journalist
nobody can do summaries better than than
Sam plus he offers um
insights penetrating insights uh unlike
virtually anybody who comes before this
committee too kind chairman but but if
you feel uncomfortable at all because uh
Mr key Williams may have key Wallace
rather may have stolen all your
thunder you don't have to but if you'd
like to we'd love to hear from you I
just I'm already sitting in the chair
I'll be very brief um
I I'll so Sam Evin Brown for the record
executive director of clean energy New
Hampshire I I'll share the same story
that I shared in the Senate which is
that as a journalist I remember the
founder of my organization uh Laura
Richardson who at that time was working
for the Jordan Institute and who was
intimately involved with the passage of
the 2010 cpay statute that never took
hold uh I remember she was making the
rounds of communities trying to convince
them to create cpce districts and and
get this program off the ground and at
that time couldn't get anyone to take
her up on it precisely because of the
flaws in the bill that that Mr key
Wallace just outlined and I remember uh
Miss Richardson sort of pleading with me
to not do a story because she didn't
want to Spook any of the towns that she
was she was trying to engage with and so
I think I actually never did the story
at the time so uh this goes all the way
back to my the very beginning of my
career as a cub reporter uh as following
this so I'm I'm very pleased that it's
passing uh or it seems on track to pass
with the bipartisan support that it has
um
my my you know my we's the beef response
to to the cpce legislation is that um
Energy Efficiency as as I think this
committee has heard uh somewhat ad
nauseum suffers from a number of market
failures um I think it it's easiest to
identifying the residential sector where
you have uh improvements that have high
upfront costs and long payback periods
and so many Energy Efficiency
improvements do pay for themselves
particularly you know there's there's
many that have a 10-year pay payback
period the average uh homeowner in the
United States only lives in their home
for eight years and so it's very
difficult to get people to to in make
that investment in their property when
they don't they're not certain about
their future they're not certain if
they're going to recoup that investment
and and so all of society suffers as a
result with less efficient housing stock
um there for a number of reasons uh uh
there there it's not considered best
practice to do SE uh Pace as a
residential product there have been
abuses uh with Pace loans in the
residential sector in the past um and so
New Hampshire gets to draft off of the
states that have made those mistakes and
and not uh introduce this as a as a
residential loan product and instead
limit it to the commercial sector where
the builders the lenders the the the
buyers and sellers of these properties
are sophisticated enough to not make the
same kind of mistakes that your average
homeowner might make um and and I would
say generally speaking one of the key
challenges of of uh the clean energy
transition that my organization is is
fond of talking about is that many of
the Investments that we're hoping
Society is going to make do pay for
themselves but it's very it's over a
very long window uh and so you're
swapping the cost of fuel for the cost
of finance and figuring out ways to
leverage low cost private Finance is an
essential tool for how we we make uh
more of these types of interventions um
cost- effective and so so in this regard
uh reducing the risk that A lender might
not get paid back for an Energy
Efficiency loan allows them to lower the
interest rate that they're they're
willing to offer the the the loan
product for and it brings in more
private Finance to do Energy Efficiency
which which ultimately is what we need I
mean there's not enough government money
in the world to to upgrade the entire
building stock of the United States we
need private lenders to do this so
really great bill um happy to take
questions but as I said to Chairman Vose
uh James ke wals really is the lending
expert
here representative Wendy thas has a
question nevertheless yes I do thank you
Mr chair and uh thank you for being here
um you're you're probably not going to
like this question but you know there
you go as someone who lives and breeds
energy um I'm going to put you on the
spot because you're very familiar with
this bill this is the third time we've
worked on it um when we replace things
um and there's a lot of replacing in
this bill there's a lot of strikeouts
often there are unintended consequences
do you see any potential poal unintended
consequences of this bill or any red
flags at all I I don't um it it actually
would have been great to have the
bankers Association here to to take that
specific question I know that they've
had input on this bill I mean the the
language that's being struck is language
that has not resulted in a single loan
being originated so it it I I struggle
to see what we'd be what what
consequence we might have on a program
that has never been never been
launched thank you
any additional
questions since I introduced the bill
I'm not allowed to ask a question but
I'm going to make a statement and you
can disagree with it if you
want the chair you can do that this bill
I think the intention of this bill is
to improve the affordable housing
situation uh so so representative
schneller asked a question of Mr James
key Wallace before which which my which
is why is there so much political
Firepower behind this bill my
understanding is that there are a number
of housing developers that are looking
at how can they get additional Capital
into their project how can they bring a
new types of lending into their Capital
stack that will help them get their
project done uh and and without cpce
lending they don't think that they will
have the capital to to do their
projects representative Matson has a
question so if it starts out with
Builder Association or whatever do doing
a group it's commercial but if they sell
a home to a person it becomes
residential does does it still follow
well so so the the this program is
limited at at five properties that are
five units or more so um so if if it
were to be sold to a person it would be
a landlord who's who's U making an
investment into a five unit or more
property um certainly it's the case that
there are some landlords you know
speaking of someone who's a landlord
myself there are some landlords who are
just regular folks and and are maybe not
that sophisticated and might might uh
might have trouble understanding the
cpce program but um but I will say you
know to I I did a bit of a deep dive
into how the original cpce uh excuse me
the original Pace residential Pace
programs the abuses that happened there
what the the key problem was that there
were contractors that were selling
improvements to homeowners and the
Energy savings of those improvements
were not being verified by anybody and
so the homeowners never saw savings
associated with those improvements uh
and then had a an additional costly lean
put on their property which then made it
more difficult for them to sell their
home uh and and I think that that uh
safeguards are in place with this
program where there's there verification
and measurement uh is is in is required
as part of the issuance of a CPAs loan
um so again we're sort of drafting on
the best practices of other communities
so I don't know if that was your
question but yeah okay
yes follow up so if a developer builds
20 homes he doesn't want to keep the 20
homes he wants everybody to buy one so
when the person buys a home from the
developer right doesn't that follow with
it so so my understanding is that those
20 homes if you're doing a standard 20
single single homes they wouldn't be
eligible under this program it would
have to be a multifam unit with five
units in one building
right at minimum of five
correct okay seeing no additional
questions I want to thank you Sam Evans
Brown for sharing your expertise with us
and your insights and with that since I
have no more pink cards I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
Z and that for the most part concludes
our business for the day there is one
other matter however that I want to uh
share with all of you and that is that I
have received fiscal notes for six
bills say nothing they for all practical
purposes say nothing um for example on
654 FN the fiscal note says the office
of legislative budget assistance States
this bill has no fiscal impact on state
county or local expenditures or
revenue and most of of the rest of these
fiscal notes basically say the same
thing however you may since we haven't
heard some of these bills you may want
to attach that fiscal note to the bill
so that when it does come us come before
us you'll have that
information there is a fiscal note on
one
bill that uh we have already heard I
believe yes so on House Bill
526 we already heard that bill and
actually um had an exec session on it
but there is a fiscal note here finally
for it so you're you're welcome to it
what I'm going to do is I'm going to put
these this stack of fiscal notes over
there on the desk and if you want to
grab one on your way out feel free to
take a copy of each one or a copy of the
ones you care about or none I I'll leave
that up to you representative partial
thank you can you tell me if uh if the
um PDFs online have been updated for the
fiscal notes are you aware I am not
aware thank you probably but I'm not
aware okay thanks representative Corman
thank you uh for the bills where the
fiscal note says that there's no fiscal
impact does that mean that if these
bills actually do pass the house they
don't have to go to a second committee
that is correct thank
you any other
questions seeing none we've done a lot
of hard work this week I want to thank
you all for two days of your attention
and your uh diligence and your
thoughtfulness uh I think we
accomplished a lot this week and we'll
do it all over again next week we'll be
here hearing 10 bills next week we'll be
hearing five bills the week after that I
believe no actually we'll be hearing 10
bills next week 10 bills the following
week and then five bills the third week
because and we'll only be uh here one
day that week because the Monday of that
week is President's Day then we'll take
the following week off which is the the
last week of February that's school
vacation week and the house tries to
discourage activity during that week and
then we'll be back the first week of
March to finish our public
hearings and then we will use the second
and third weeks of March to have
executive sessions on any bills that we
don't hear between now and then so
that's the schedule going forward
representative McGee thank you um I was
just wondering about the sixth and
whether the six bills that we've already
exact are going to be heard should we be
preparing over the weekend or testimony
on any of these excellent question yes
all of the bills that we've heard that
we've exact so far will be in the
calendar this week for next Thursday's
house session so if there are any floor
debates that you anticipate you should
begin to prepare for those floor
debates representative Wendy Thomas um
yes I'm just um verifying don't you have
a birthday during that week that we're
not
meeting yes I do have a birthday that
week and we'll be traveling well happy
birthday in advance well thank you I
appreciate that where Senator Shaheen
and I uh were born just 28 29 days apart
in
1947 anything else all right have a
great rest of the week and a great
weekend we'll see you next week take
care